this is Jocko podcast number 113 with
echo Charles and me Jocko Willick
good evening echo good evening I
instantly lifted my m4 as my eyes
scanned the terrain above us I knew
without looking that John and the other
guys were moving as soon as my weapon
came up Reno took off at a dead sprint
and disappeared 20 feet to our left
seconds afterward screams came from the
area I moved forward scanning the
environment as I moved wanting to come
to Reno's aid as soon as possible but
unwilling to leave behind my tactical
sense I heard three shots ring out as a
Taliban fighter tried to exit the
shallow cut that they had been hiding in
his companion was locked in a fight with
Reno the dog was destroying his opponent
blood quickly covering the man's clothes
I called Reno out of the fight and
squeezed off several rounds as the man
reached for his weapon we quickly
searched the area before moving on our
pace even quicker than before the
gunfire for sure had given away our
position
legs and lungs burned the elevation
taking its toll as we finally reached
our destination sitting on the edge of
that mountain waiting for a ride I
looked back at the last few hours I
patted Reno's head twice tonight he had
saved my life twice I owed him yet
another debt of gratitude his body
shivered slightly as the cold wind bit
into him now that we weren't moving the
cold settled quickly I pulled off my
coat and wrapped them in it pulling his
body against mine to keep him warm
tonight he had saved my life tonight he
had saved my brother's lives and that is
a little excerpt from the book Trident
k9 warriors my tale from the training
ground to the battlefield with elite
Navy SEAL canines by Mike Ritland a CEO
who ended
working with dogs training dogs and
eventually starting a company called tri
Coase international that trains dogs for
for the most elite forces in the world
and that was an excerpt that was from an
operator talking about one of the dogs
that Mike had trained and Mike's written
two other books
besides Trident k9 warriors he also
wrote team dog and Navy SEAL dogs which
is a book aimed at teenagers and tonight
we are lucky enough to have Mike with us
on the podcast to talk about how the
hell he ended up doing what he is doing
so Mike Ritland welcome aboard it's a
both a pleasure and an honor to be here
I appreciate you having me so we always
have to start where you started tell us
a little bit about Waterloo Iowa well
it's uh you know it's one of those one
of those spots where I guess it's a good
place to be from not a whole lot
happening in Iowa which honestly is why
part of the reason why I got in the dogs
because there's not a whole lot else
going on wrestling obviously is huge in
Iowa and I had the the pleasure of
growing up during the Gabel era of Iowa
wrestling and my dad wrestled with Dan
Gable in high school and so you know
being kind of engrained in that culture
growing up even though I never wrestled
because he he can hardly walk and is so
beat up from it he swam and so all of us
swam long story short there's still a
big part of my life but so I you know
growing up kind of having that mentality
ingrained you know was a big big
proponent of where I'm at today and and
why I got involved in both the Navy and
and dogs because of the appreciation for
you know for that mentality terms of
Waterloo it's you know suburban town
70,000 people
I'd say lower middle class probably a
lot of influence from Chicago Milwaukee
st. Louis pretty
ruff high school growing up there it
wasn't wasn't the best of times for me
but taught me a lot of hard lessons
about perseverance and doing things even
when you don't want to do them and
facing things that you're not not
willing to be comfortable with facing
and things of that nature and and I was
on the swim team and influenced by my
grandfather's in terms of their service
in world war two and and I just always
wanted to make a an impact in terms of
serving my country I know I'm a little
younger than you but for me I was in
junior high when the first Gulf War
broke out and it scared scared the crap
out of me a couple years later I was
like where do I sign up you know that
that progression you know just in that
couple of year period is just crazy but
but it you know those those experiences
and seeing some some terrorist activity
as a young kid growing up it really
really shaped no different than than how
it shapes you know the guys were
constantly going against in the in the
generations growing up which has a huge
impact but from a recruiting standpoint
but but yeah I mean it was just
something that blue-collar town
patriotic grandfather's were were pipe
hitters in the World War two and and
what they do in World War two it's my my
mom's dad was on a minesweeper and the
Navy also cook less straight out of you
know Navy it's Steven Seagal just to
cook but he was just to cook but he used
on a fleet of mine sweepers was 98 and
the fleet in the Mediterranean and two
of them came back and he was on one of
them my dad's dad was in the army he
actually just tells you how times have
changed he he beaten at an English
allied soldier to death in a bar fight
somewhere in Europe during the war and
they just sent him home and discharged
him you know but I didn't I didn't know
him real well and I met him a couple of
times he had a pretty rough rough go you
know after after the war and I was
basically an alcoholic and I only saw
him three or four times maybe growing up
before he died but but my mom's dad is
it was a huge influence you know I
talked with him a lot of I was always
fascinated by you know his stories and
his outlook and and just you know he
wasn't wasn't you know aversive to
talking about it
enjoyed talking about it but yeah just
it was very inspiring and and it just
made me want to serve you know I've kind
of always leveraged my decisions in life
on how I'm gonna make the most bang for
my buck and get the most out of every
decision and I felt like you know it was
it was my my turn to you know carry the
torch for a little bit how did you hear
about the teams I was a Popular
Mechanics article that I read in like
ninth grade and that was the first time
I'd ever heard of it uh and it showed
you know like you know to me like one of
the things that I think recruits a lot
of us is saying that it's it's actually
the toughest military training they've
learned by default I'm gonna go do that
then for sure so that was part of it but
yeah I mean I read that of that and and
that was at a time when I was getting
you know I got got rolled up pretty hard
a few times in high school got jump yeah
yeah you were talking about that in your
first book yeah you got rolled up a
couple times and beat down oh yeah yeah
I was I was a runt in high school like
my freshman year I was 5'4 105 pounds
that's fun and then I was one of
happened you know juniors and seniors
just you know whaling on me and you know
I didn't I didn't have much of a chance
there but you know and even when I
graduated I was the same height I am now
and I weighed 140 you know so when I my
first first ID in the Navy I was 145 and
I'm 511 you know so yeah I put on a few
pounds so did you did you do dive fair
program or anything like that I didn't
uh when I originally tried to be a
corpsman and at that time this was 96
they're like yeah we're pretty heavy on
corpsman pick something else and I was
like how about Intel specialist you know
so I went to is a school right out of
boot camp and I when I graduated high
school I was 17 still so I had to wait
until I turned 18 go to boot camp so I
went to boot camp in August is a school
and checked into buds in spring of 97
that I was a youngest youngest guy in
the class and I hold the whole deal what
did you weigh then I worked out pretty
heavy in a school I got up to about 155
I think oh yeah I mean I I mean I see
pictures of
like you know post tell week in first
phase like I look like I just broke out
out with ya I mean there's nothing to me
you know yeah but I read 175 when I
showed up Simon yeah 511 175 then I
could weighed 185 when I graduated cuz I
put on 10 pounds yeah I did the same I
weighed 165 I think if you're a little
bit's cuz I was like a scrawny I know
175 might not sound scrawny but I wasn't
I was pretty scrawny 175 and then they
they put a little meat on the bones as
they say you can eat whatever I would
order a Domino's cheese pizza extra
cheese pizza just about every night now
I had a same similar ritual you remember
the country store yeah so at the end of
every day after dinner I would go to the
country store and there was that little
McDonald's next to oh yeah you'd get
something I'd get a quarter pounder with
cheese value meal in a box literally a
box of ten oatmeal cream pies and a
64-ounce leaded Gatorade every night and
wolfed it down no problem yeah and I
gained like eight pounds duh the thing
is and I was telling somebody about this
you know you run to chow and Jack every
every meal you run to chow it's a mile
there that's a mile back yeah and you go
three or four times a day for because
sometimes you go up midnight so that
means you're running between 6 and 8
miles everyday before you even include
any of the actual training so you're
doing a lot of physical activity you can
eat a lot done especially at that age
too oh yeah that's right and then a
couple it was being cold
most of the day that's true yeah you're
burning I wonder what you're burning for
calories it's a massive amount of gout
this is that'll be 10 K Plus yeah yeah I
didn't even think about the cold part oh
yes you are just cold all the time just
hammering calories away you get done
with buds and and you you were a swimmer
right I was there one of those people
that I talk about like swimming was for
you is just super easy actually no I got
I got rolled I started with 214 I got
rolled six days before going to San
Clemente Island for swims no loser that
so the here's that I pinched my sciatic
nerve at that look kind of doin land now
it's not a loser so I just failed
everything but it's kind of the kind of
a running joke like now I got rolled for
swims because the first thing that I
failed three of I failed everything
after Laguna cuz it with the injury but
I will say that because I grew up in
Iowa like that my first time in the
ocean was it buds like mean I had been
knee high water at Cocoa Beach on spring
break or whatever but I'd never been out
past a surf I'd never swam at night and
good freaked you out a little bit I mean
it was just kind of is like an over over
stimulus type thing but for me you know
not having a black line to look at you
know and having a guide off the coast
you know it was a bit of a challenge but
that for me the biggest thing was
actually swimming with fins yeah that's
you know what that's a good point
because a good point people it's a
totally different muscle yeah well and
you're you know from from having so I
mean I grew up when I was from five
until I graduated high school I mean I
had partial scholarship offers you know
to some local colleges for swimming and
and you know for me it was it came
pretty naturally I was never a state
champion but I went to state and did all
right but you know show us so growing up
with that muscle memory of how to swim
without ever using fins why not the
first time I put those on those duct for
your like two by fours you know I mean
they just destroyed my ankles especially
being kind of scrawny way so for the
first phase like my feet and ankles were
just destroyed the whole time you know
like for me it was hard to swim and I
mean I could pass but I wasn't I wasn't
you know the guys out in the front just
turtle back there no having fun who are
those guys I mean there was some Olympic
swimmers yeah and water polo players
yeah see I I had a couple of those guys
were
I just thought these guys are just studs
but they were swimmers yeah so that's
why I figured you were breezing through
the swims too
no I mean I you know they didn't they
didn't bother me you know but I was
middle of the road I wasn't I wasn't
blowing anybody out of the water I think
for them some of it is it you know in
Iowa we were probably a little behind
the power curve technology-wise now they
do use a lot of fins little cheater fins
and training fins and stuff and so
there's some more to it than that plus
the guys that I saw that did really well
were
more muscular than I was you know for me
is like those fins were about a quarter
of my body weight you know and it was
literally was like having concrete she
was going for a jog it was like yeah it
didn't do me any favours it took some
getting used to for sure but the runs
and swims I think what about the runs
runs no problem you look you know really
there was nothing that I I would say
that I struggled with I wasn't the best
at everything that I you know I wasn't
getting good either yeah you know I was
kind of a grey man on purpose which is
the best place to be and one of my
buddies he would say that they started
the goon squad every single time with
him yeah moon squad if you're if you're
slow on the run and you get to sort of
the end and then there's a structure
waiting and these from this point on
you're getting gooned which means you're
gonna do a bunch of crap and it's gonna
suck and this guy was the beginning of
the goon squad every time which is not
fun yeah so what year was it when you
graduate a bunch so it was a spring of
98 and then you went to team three yeah
when I went to boot camp or Benning jump
school oh okay yeah back when they still
did that and then and then from there
straight to team three and an ST T and
and I got my did the Chiefs Board thing
which was I wish they still did that you
know I think that's a sacrilege that
they do it the way they do it now but
yeah I got got might ride in an October
of 98 waited until January to climb to
jump into my first platoon and that was
an Arg alpha platoon so it's not only
two-month work up with six months of
fleet X ship deployments prior to even
deploying I did two args yeah yeah
back-to-back args a team won't park in
the dirt I think they're valuable what
ship did you do boy out the Duluth oh
right on LP d6 yeah yeah man so that
things from 1965 or 67 or something like
Vietnam yeah yeah they built these ships
echo to take troops from here to Vietnam
drop them off but then by the time we
were on them they were just doing full
six-month deployment so it was
straight-up World War two style canvas
racks so little canvas racks there'd be
four people sleeping stacked up like
four bunks with these little canvas
racks this is old-school
but I will say this I mean the
experience is in terms of big Navy like
you don't get those four shows you know
for sure and doing the fleet access we
were on the Abraham Lincoln and got to
stand on the bridge watching f-14s land
and take off and you know we got to do
some pretty neat stuff that that I'm
glad glad we got to be a part of what
was awesome for me was we were doing
because when you're when you're with
them you're with the Marine Corps and so
we did all these operations in
conjunction with the Marine Corps so I
was a comms guy what were you until guy
so I was a comms guy so I was always
interacting with all the other units
that we'd be out there for
communications and then coordinating and
all that stuff so I had a real leg up
when it came to working with
conventional forces which if you were an
irregular spec ops platoon back then you
would never work with them I mean you
barely very rarely work with
conventional forces so I did two args
where I got to work with Marines and do
massive you know battalion-sized
operations and had to coordinate all
those things so it it gave me a good
introduction you'd get you'd get guys
back in the teams back then they they
wouldn't even know they wouldn't even
know they wouldn't even understand what
a Marine Corps battalion was or what a
company was or want a platoon was they
just wouldn't know now everybody knows
we've gotten more professional as times
gone by but that gave me a I was real
lucky that I had that Arak plutonium in
like I said it's just getting a you know
kind of the the big Navy perspective on
a lot of things I think is is valuable
you know and and it was just neat from a
for me at least from a tradition
standpoint I mean because we we did a
about a three-week exercise in Australia
where we tested out a fast catamaran
that they were testing for for up for us
basically the thought was is this thing
to do like 55 knots you know and it's
the size of a you know it's bigger than
like a guided missile cruiser man a
medium sized ship with you know a hole
in the middle as a cat but so the the
thought process was we could deploy like
a whole task element or at least a
platoon if you remember the I think they
were with the hurricane class or
whatever those little osw amphibious
goats that was kind of the same
principal and they they candid after a
while but same kind of principle is that
but these things do 55 knots and it was
weird you know we're out floating around
testing these things out doing some some
exercises of some nor force Australian
guys and it what it was more like being
on a plane than a boat in terms of the
way it felt like when you're trying to
sleep or whatever I mean imagine a boat
that big doing 55 knots it's crazy
that's completely crazy yeah but you
could put everything you know you could
do a full task element load out on it be
completely self sustained and go 55
knots anywhere in the world you know so
it certainly had some potential but
obviously we never ended up doing them
but are getting them or implementing
them so how many deployments did you do
before the war kicked off just that one
so that was because it took so long as
22 month workup then you did a six-month
deployment yeah then you come back from
that well so yeah the the kind of the
raw deal that I guess couldn't call it a
raw deal but for me so we got back in
February of 2001 mid-february and
because it was right in the middle of
force 21 reorg that's right so it was
team 3 their official force 21 form up
wasn't until January of Oh - so from
February to January the entire team was
basically like on pro dev or whatever
and you know I'd only done one platoon
so they're like yeah you're not going to
freefall yet now we've got two other
guys going to sniper so you can go to
hazmat that's cool awesome how about you
can be a bus driver so I ended up
actually going over the sysm team I
don't know if you're mad because you're
a swimmer Navy pentathlon
yeah you know at Team three I was always
like when we did run swim runs you know
is one thing being a little smaller at
that time and being a good swimmer and a
pretty decent runner I could always get
top three top five at that the team on
any given day doing swims and runs and
so I went over and tried out and made
the team and competed and we were
supposed to compete in Istanbul that
summer did the whole you know train for
six months and and busted my my backside
and then I pull I pulled more tore my
groin
and and I just I couldn't I couldn't get
it healed in time and so I ended up not
not being able to go compete which
really sucked I was I was looking
forward to doing it but it was a neat
experience so it's totally different it
was you know the first time in my life
and the only time it was like being a
professional athlete you know we'd we'd
train for 3-4 hours in the morning and
then swim for two and a half hours in
the afternoon to a Saturday long long
run or long practice and that was it the
rest isms stand for its I mean it's not
even in English I don't think it's it's
basically like military Olympics behind
go yes it's the Navy pentathlon so it's
okay so the the event what are the
events it's so it's an old course but
it's a totally different you know it's a
real squirrlio course and I'm all right
yeah small yeah you just it's really
fast like it's one every sprint yeah so
there's that there's a like a you know
what they call it it's like a naval
traditional race thing where you're
paddling a little boat and you go out
around a dinghy and have to do shackles
whatever
what's shackles well like you like it's
a little like you go around a buoy and
have to take a shackle off and connect
it to something else like it's so
there's a little tradition so challenge
yeah same thing with the underwater Oh
course which that one was pretty legit
it's a hundred and twenty-five yard
underwater ops of course and you got
those big three-foot carbon-fiber
freedive fins on so you do I mean it's
like you're like I couldn't have these
and but it's like you're thinking about
combat swimmer like I'm gonna steal some
of these but yeah I mean so I'd say 90%
of that hundred and twenty five yard
race is underwater you know you only
come up at the at the end blow out and
take a breath like a like a damn Orca
you know you're just like you know and
go right now are you doing tasks
underwater yeah so there's there's a
like a cargo net with a hole at the
bottom you gotta you know and this is
over the sea TT in the 15 foot section
so you're going from the top down to the
bottom and then back to the top at the
other side and so the only time you're
taking a breath is at the end and I will
tell you from a physical standpoint like
that was one of the more taxing things
I've ever done
because it's a race and it's technique
and whatever but so there's a cargo net
you got to go under you got to swim a
rubber m16 from one side to the next
holding it out of the water but you're
you know you're basically your whole
body's underwater with just the rifle
out in your streamline and whatever it's
all technique stuff that you're you know
whatever and then you have to go down
you know you go to one side come back so
basically you swim the m16 across you
drop it you swim all the way down
through that hole come back up swim back
down to back to the other side and undo
this little like firehose shackle thing
and put it back together come up and
then sprint back to the other side type
of thing and that was pretty pretty
challenging but so there's that and then
there's a life-saving thing where you
gotta do it you know save a dummy
basically they have to get out of your
clothes and so like you're wearing these
old buds greens and they're all like
rigged so that you can get out of them
like literally you undo the pants you
know and like it's this whole technique
thing you can go from having full greens
on in the lot taking them off in the
water by doing like this porpoise
backflip thing and you backflip out of
them and then go save the guy and it's
it's really kind of dumb honestly it's
all like I feel ridiculous even I
explain it like it sounds even more
stupid you're explaining it to you guys
not knowing what it is but but yeah so
so there were some underwater [ __ ] going
on yeah that's basically what I'm here
yeah so that thing you can't go because
you you get injured and now so so
shortly after you were supposed to
compete if that supposed to be in the
summer of 2001 September 11th goes down
yeah you you get rolled back into a
platoon at that point well so I did a
couple of Intel schools some secret
scroll ones that were actually pretty
awesome during that summer after I got
hurt and then I literally in fact one of
them I I flew back the night before
September 11th on September 10th I flew
from from DC to San Diego I get home
September 11th happens I'm on my butt we
were living in the HOH at the time I was
on my way and the SEAL team three you
know you know getting ready to jump in a
platoon when it happened and so
obviously like with everybody you know
all bets are off and figuring out what
we're gonna do there was an exercise in
Jordan that they sent me on
a couple weeks later and they beefed it
up pretty heavy like it was gonna be a
you know minimal footprint but after
September 11th they ended up sin and way
more people and a lot more resources it
kind of set it up almost like a like a
like a potential fob if need be you know
they had a couple platoons worth of guys
and and you know people with experience
and brought real stuff and you know kind
of a contingent if need be I'm you know
nothing we didn't end up doing anything
but but we spent actually almost two
months over there right after September
11 is almost like a mini deployment as
well but got back from that and jumped
into my platoon in January and then it
was you know
full speed ahead like I mean not that I
know you were same way it's not that you
weren't training for war before but
there was definitely it was very purpose
yeah and then you you you deploy and you
did the you did the oil rigs right I did
so you know we're just kind of you know
lucky luck of the draw I guess you know
we we were originally slated to be a
Paycom platoon we're gonna go to Guam
and when we did but you know so I
actually reenlist stood to go to Arabic
school and at DLI and I was one of my
things I wanted to learn Arabic and so
they they were supposed to honor that
and then we got Reese laid it as a PACOM
platooning like now you're going to
learn Tagalog instead congratulations
it's like you got to kidding me so he
speak Tagalog I wouldn't say I speak
yeah not at DLI they so they you know in
true Navy fashion it's like you're not
going to Arabic you're not going to DLI
you're learning Tagalog and it's gonna
be at North Island for three months
straight okay so it's not the same yeah
but yeah I mean I can carry on a basic
conversation with it but so anyway would
go to go to Guam this is like October
roof of o2 and and then you know we're
we did the standard PACOM deployment but
towards the end of the year they
basically you know the writing was on
the wall like Iraq's gonna kick off so
team 5 came and back filled us and Itay
I don't know that they could have been
any more pissed oh yeah you know like
our turnover party almost was nine
fistfights you know like but they were
pretty salty about it I don't blame them
but so they had to come take our place
and finish out our pack on deployment so
we could go to Kuwait Wow
those guys must have been pissed they're
beyond pissed there's there's a feeling
that we won't be able to replicate for a
long time which is guys that had never
been to war the desire that you had to
to go because you think you're only
gonna get like one mission everyone at
that time you're like thinking if you
get to do some kind of real mission
you'll be just completely your life that
will be complete and you think if you
don't get to do that you're never then
opportunities never gonna get there and
and so that's why I can't even imagine
what was going through those guys heads
at the time yeah I mean like so they
they had that exact just pit in their
stomach like were this close and you
guys you know you've already been here
like and we it was kind of the best of
both worlds because you know we went to
the Philippines for a while which that
was nice speaking Tagalog there you know
we were there for a month and then we
went to Singapore for a while we you
know hit Thailand I mean it was a
good-good PACOM deployment spent some
time ago and went to Hawaii and did like
a three week exercise around Christmas
you know and then but yeah so you know
come late January they're like you know
they fly on all of our desert stuff and
I would totally repurpose in all of our
crap and and then we flew through
Thailand land and Kuwait set up shop at
Kuwaiti naval base for about six weeks
while we're getting ready and so during
that time the the oil rig in tailed me
being the Intel rep like I was sourcing
Intel from a lot of different sources
and they weren't very well corroborated
like some of them who's kind of like on
one end of the spectrum it was like yeah
it's not that big a deal and then on the
other one was like dude this is a
suicide mission you know and everything
in between and so it was a little bit
nerve-wracking because it bounced around
a lot it was like you know how there's
there's nobody on board and then it's
like now there's four guys and you know
they saw a couple aks and next thing you
know it's like yeah there's 115 people
and they're all suicide vest it up and
you know they're gonna clack off when
you guys step on you know it's just
and I just like said it bounced around
but during that time like all we did was
CQC and and we built actually a
full-scale mock-up now mind you this
target was 1600 meters long I mean it
took us seven hours to take it down and
but you know SD
we did a recon on it beforehand and when
you see he built a full mock-up we mean
I mean I say that I you know we didn't
have the funds of some of the other
units to do that stuff with but it was
basically size-wise we laid out like
record tapes tapes like normally like
wood stake on an end God and twine yeah
but just to know like hey this is
legitimately how wrong it is to give you
a real idea because you know so there
was birthing at one end and that's where
we hit it at the beginning because it
was in the middle of night that's where
they all were and so we took took was 32
32 prisoners without without really any
any real issue breached a bunch of doors
and took down the whole birthing and and
then swept the whole rest of the thing
from one end to the next and like I said
it took took all night but so yeah we
did that and and and then came back from
that and and then from there just it was
basically hey you know everybody load up
the wars kickin off and the one thing I
will say it was really neat about that
mission though is that it was the entire
team and I think to this day it's still
the largest single in terms of you know
participants special operations mission
in NSW history is because it was the
entire team in the coordination effort
because there was a manifold metering
station on the beach and then there's 26
miles of pipelines that were 48 inch
pipes you know there was like 30
exxon-valdez worth of oil in these just
in the pipelines and the worry was and
the reason we had to coordinate it was
that you know the the manifold metering
station there's people manning that and
there's people on the on the oil rig and
all that pipeline if they blow that like
it's gonna destroy the whole goal yeah
and we'll be the 48-inch pipes
yeah yeah I mean you walk around in them
that's crazy and there was like four of
them you know so but yeah so basically
we had to coordinate with and again we
actually had an STV platoon with us so
it was us in an SD v1 platoon they hit
the the there was two different oil rigs
there was the may bot and chaotic
the MENA al-bakr oil terminal and then
the coral amaya oil terminal the K bot 1
or K OTT you know the Grom guys took
down the fact there was nobody on that
and then we took down the the one with
you know with all the people on it but
we had to coordinate it basically time
and exact with the other four platoons
from team three one of which was a DP DP
v platoon when they were still used Jack
I think that's probably the mission
where they decided to can the program
yeah they were terrible yeah all got
stuck it was amazing there's a mess but
but you know so they they met some
resistance there and just echo that a DP
V is like a desert betrays a desert
patrol vehicle but it looks like like a
dune buggy and and they and who actually
looks even super cooler than they got
big leg guns when you're a kid and you
see that thing
it's your ultimate fantasy in life
coming true to see this badass dune bug
guns with guns all over it rockets on it
and you think oh this is if you would
have seen those when you were you know
13 years old you'd say whoever how
whatever I gotta do my life drive that
thing is what I'm gonna do
the problem was there they're real
specific and finicky and and they get
stuck yeah that's the bottom line it's
like I mean they're worse than Humvees
yeah yeah so they took that down and we
and we timed it basically where you know
it was a simultaneous hitter or
staggered by you know ten seconds but so
that you know they the the worry was
that if we took it down too early then
they would know and yeah and vice versa
so so yeah we had to had to coordinate a
pretty pretty spot-on but but we pulled
it off they managed to take out a few
guys on the manifold side we didn't have
any real resistance no shots fired other
than breaching doors on RN but so we
rendezvous back at a Kuwaiti naval base
and then we jetted up to Ali ah Saleem
air force base in northern Kuwait and
then spent the next few days just
bloating for Humvees out and then and
again this was the start of the war we
actually only had three and we ended up
we snaked one from the Air Force
and I don't know if I should say it I'm
gonna say it anyway but there was a
green green Humvee that a couple of our
guys walked over to a parking lot and
stole it and brought it brought it over
and we spent one night literally with
two cans of tans paint and a paintbrush
and just painted it their hands and then
these were soft doors you know you know
we had extra crappy body armor that we'd
hang in the doors to try to give us some
protection whatever and yeah we just
were like well we're loading up we did
have a guy there's his first Platoon and
he was he kind of lost his lost his
marbles on the on the hit like he was he
was rattled to the point where you know
he basically gave up and hung it up
didn't come with us no he was a 60
gunner and so yeah we had a had an Intel
guy at the time that was not a team guy
that is now that jumped in a spot
basically he talked about like old
school like I know they wouldn't they
wouldn't let that stuff happen now is
better like here's a here's a 60 you
know man up yeah sit in the door and yet
but that's that's cool that's also
interesting you know people always it's
one of those kind of myths or
misconceptions where people think that
everyone that's the steals like a
hundred percent and there you go you got
a guy that did one operation and said
I'm not going any further I remember I
think there was a couple guys on the
west coast that turned their birds in
after 9/11 you know like I didn't sign
up for this like what did you sign up
for yeah you know but yeah I mean and
there was a couple instances to where
you know you'd find out things about
guys that just like being a buds
instructor um don't ever count anybody
out don't ever bet on anybody know
there's people it'll surprise you both
ways yeah I always feel like somebody
who's asked me that the other day I
always feel like you can you can get an
indication right like you go you know
what this guy's pretty hardcore yeah you
know I I'd go I'd go 80% you know maybe
90% and you think ah this guy's pretty
weak I'd go 80% 90% but there's like you
said there's outliers or there's people
that you just think of what the what
just happened to that guy yeah and it's
another thing I'm had I'm having to
contend with now as I get a little bit
older is
fact that even though I'm all about
human nature and all this stuff and like
I really want to understand people
sometimes I just look at him look I
don't literally don't understand what
your problem is
yeah why would a big one so there was a
there was a Navy ship out in front of my
house the other day and I took a picture
of it and I sent it to like Lafe and JP
and and Dave Burke and influent Cochran
and I was like the Navy was good to me
but I don't miss these big great
monsters right and Lafe wrote back you
know he's like yeah I mean that was my
motivation going through butts there's
no way and and everyone kind of agreed
everyone was like there's no way I was
gonna quit buds and go to a ship which
is not exactly is it well if you have
the personality where you think you want
to go to buds then being on a ship is
completely the opposite of that
personality so I don't understand how a
guy could be you know it get get to a
point where they say you know what I
don't want to be wet cold anymore which
is really all it is you know people get
all excited about SEAL training but
you're wet and you're cold and you're
tired okay that that's that's what
that's not that big of a deal the
pamphlet is 10% of the job yeah jack
yeah so you get some people that I guess
they don't really want to do it
everybody wants to be a frogman on a
sunny day yeah that's that's another
good scene so so you guys pushed up into
Iraq yeah so we rolled up and the neat
thing at the time was was mattis was the
was the you know he was the the boss of
one Mar div at the time so we rolled up
with the first Marine Division linked up
with the 13th or 15th mute in Nazarene
they had taken some some headaches it
was a big fight and and so the the word
that we got and again you'd have to talk
to to Harwood and mattis if that's how
it went down but basically we got mad
it's called Harwood was like hey you
know some of our supply routes and
convoys have been getting it handed to
them and in some some routes and Nazeri
oh you guys go ambush the ambushers and
like hell yeah we will you know so it
was like the wet dream of of what you
would think you're getting yourself into
combat wise in terms of it was
you know hey our conventional guys are
getting getting it taken to them
here is your your grid square basically
it's your territory let us know what we
can do to help you guys have at it and
we had some leadership at the time that
was not that crazy about cutting us off
lead you know and so we battled it out
with him and Kate came up with some
creative ways to go out and work anyway
but but we just you know we went out and
and did like old school you know
conducting our own everything you know I
mean we we gather our own intelligence
we you know grabbed a few guys and asked
around and and you know did several hits
based on the intelligence that we'd
gathered and had air support and it was
kind of like a little microcosm of what
was to come
you know but was that the first time you
saw dogs in action
no okay no it wasn't until after that
and and it wasn't even seeing them it
was hearing about them which I'll get to
in a second I guess but so the nazriya
thing were there for for a few weeks
just doing our own doing our own thing
basically then we went up to Southern
Baghdad just south of Baghdad and were
there for just a couple of days then we
were in northern Baghdad we had a scud
base which was cool um you know took a
scud base down and got got some pretty
neat photos and experiences from from
that but took down a Scott base and got
cool pics
I should accomplished yeah yeah I mean
got the t-shirt so uh so after that then
we went up to Tikrit you know and so
this was you know again this was during
the conventional phase it was kind of to
me the unique part about that was was
it's kind of the best of both worlds it
was like having box seats at a historic
combat scene in terms of big
conventional forces moving through you
know there were there were lines you
know everything and so you know I don't
I don't know if you remember the I think
it was a third ID he was supposed to
come down through Turkey and in the last
minute they said no you're not doing it
so everything you know was supposed to
be meeting like that and in Baghdad with
the you know the Army and the Marines
meeting south-to-north squeeze in
Baghdad and
and it didn't happen you know last
minute when they said no you can't run
through here so it was just you know the
Marines moving south to north and and so
we there was a couple times where we'd
go ahead of them and scout out some
routes and and got into a little bit of
trouble a few times and then as we're
coming up you know to Crete and Mosel
and uh you know Tala far--and and you
know some of the curd curd areas up
there they weren't real worried about
Tikrit was kind of the last big one that
they were worried about being a lasting
because it was Saddam's hometown
whatever and so the entire first Marine
Division and SEAL team three echo
platoon took down Tikrit and it was
funny because they're like you know you
know 1st 1st division has the West you
know 2nd Scott the North thirds got the
south and team three echo platoon you
guys are taking these like you know
there's 16 of us often soft-skinned
Humvees right yeah whatever so we got it
yeah we went skirted skirted through
town while while the entire town of you
know 25,000 Marines were taking down to
Crete were sneaking our way up to up to
the the palace and we took the palace
down which is pretty pretty neat and
stayed there for for a little while and
then ended up once we left there we've
kind of bounced around and went down
back down to Baghdad and flew out but
but so while I was in Tikrit that's
where you know we had been in scenarios
where the gist of it was that there was
a group of Marines that had a dog with
them and there was a one of the way I
described in the book was you know again
it was hearing you know these guys were
getting ready to there's a little
opening like kind of a cave complex
style opening on the side of a hill and
they had a single-purpose bomb dog with
him again from this is all just what I
heard and there was a grenade booby trap
basically a clump of grenades just
inside the doorway that that this dog
had alerted on you know and for me that
was like the slap in the face light
switch moment of like why why do we not
have dogs and I had grown up in Iowa
with bird dogs I got into hog
for a number of years after which I'll
get into the kind of what I drew from
that in terms of heart intensity
conditioning training nutrition breeding
Theory stuff like that but but you know
I'd spent a number of years prior to
that dealing with dogs working with them
training them stuff like that but never
you know this focused and strategic
about it calculated and so for me it was
just from that day on back in March of
oh three up until as I said here it was
just like I couldn't get enough of it
you know and I had taken a lot of the
lessons I learned from training and and
breeding and working with dogs in in a
more informal capacity and applied a lot
of that stuff to to what what I had had
started implementing with with the k9
programs and stuff and so for for that
first five years it was just kind of you
know a student to me I'm still a student
but but it was just you know training
with whoever I could train with I would
import dogs I would you know go to clubs
I'd you know try to work with police
departments anybody I could work with I
would do it I'd read every book I could
watch videos went to seminars you name
it and and then as I transitioned to get
ready to get out after I got you know I
came back was an instructor for a little
while got Valley fever and lost you know
40% of my lungs and and then as I was
getting ready to get out I could either
stay in and be a handler on the west
coast or start my own company and you
know provide dogs training and their
courses and make a bigger impact and for
me that was I'd say just kind of breezed
through the fact that you got Valley
fever as an instructor in lost 40% lost
where you played along and it kills some
people and that's that was obviously a
huge piece of you saying because if you
would have stayed in you you you weren't
allowed to do anything that had any kind
of lung irritants was the deal yes oh so
this was you know I came back and and
and went right into being an instructor
I had planned on you know forwarding on
to bigger and better things
operationally and you know it I was out
at Nylund and I all of a sudden just
like any of us after you shoot a an 84
or or a Gustav round more than a couple
of them your chest a little tight the
next day
I was you know the RSO during 55 of a
big shot you know and so naturally like
yeah my justice tightness that shouldn't
be legal by the way as we found out so
just there anyone know a carl gustaf or
an 84 but especially a carl gustav it's
the biggest boom you're shooting eighty
four millimeter rocket and if you shoot
two of them or three of them in a day
it's it's like you got punched in the
head a bunch but the problem is our
instructor staff goes out there and they
sit there and do would you say fifty
five and five fifty five and one day
that's not healthy bro oh no that is not
healthy yeah and it was one of those
things like well you're not shooting
them you're just standing there so it
doesn't count it's like okay you know
typical military genius you know but so
the next day you know but i expected my
chest and lungs and head and everything
to be a little a little sore than normal
but it got worse and i got to the point
where three or four days after that it
was like it was debilitating you know it
felt like you were standing on my chest
especially when I laid down it got worse
and so finally they said you know hey
you need to go to Balboa and hit the hit
the ER and see what the hell's going on
and so I went and it took you know based
on and I can't blame Balboa like based
on what I told them naturally they're
assuming blast lung you know type type
of issues you know some sort of you know
explosive type of damage but it wasn't
you know what that did is it exacerbated
what had already started which was me
having breathed in coccidia mycosis
which is a microscopic fungus that lives
in arid climates and it spreads through
your lungs like mold where it gets
dangerous and kills people's is two
things one your genetic makeup be
predisposed to determine you know how
how big of an impact it has the other
one is how much you're exposed to and
how long it goes untreated so I
basically it grows through your your
lungs like mold and spreads but if it if
it goes past that if it disseminates
past your lungs then it goes into your
in your blood and your organs and your
bone and then ultimately it'll get into
your your CSF fluid or cerebral spinal
fluid and into your spinal cord and go
up in your brain and that's when it
kills people and so it's it's kind of
like encephalitis
that way but so mine had had
disseminated past my lungs there was a
couple of hot spots in my in my chest
bin my sternum and and in my chest bone
ribs and whatever and so when they
caught it they they prescribed lamisil
which was a toenail fungus medication
but no I'm sorry diflucan but it's it's
a lot harsher than lamisil it's
fluconazole and so they long story short
I was on 28 times the amount that you
would be prescribed for for a bad case
of toenail fungus and I got down so
here's the irony I had gotten up to 200
pounds prior to that and then I got back
down I weighed 140 pounds at the end of
it I was on convalescent leave for 8
months
at the time my my chief was ty woods you
know from Magothy God rest his soul that
awesome dude but so I was working for
him at the time and he you know just
couldn't have been better I mean he
checked on me came by the house
regularly I mean you know I mean I
couldn't do anything like I slept 20
hours a day I was like heaven pneumonia
and mono at the same time lost a ton of
weight got down to about 140 finally
they had they had gotten the disease
under control and got it to to recede
but it lays in your bloodstream like
malaria does or whatever that lays
dormant so if I got pneumonia or
leukemia or HIV or cancer or something
that really immunosuppressed me it could
come back and so that's it's always
there you always have antibodies there
but so at the end of that the infectious
disease captain at Balboa sat me down
he's like you know I would recommend a
medical retirement for you right now and
he said if you want to go that route I'm
not saying you have to but but that's
what I recommend and you know he
basically let me know what you want to
do and I was like man I you know I've
got a child on my first child on the way
I have no college degree I had he's
totally caught me off guard like I have
no plan you know and so I said well you
know how can I stay in you know he said
well you got to stay away from from lung
irritants for a few years honestly he's
like to make as good a recovery as
you're gonna make you
to slowly get back into shape and put
weight on you got to take really good
care of your lungs I mean we stay away
from harsh cleaning products smoke you
know dust everything which is basically
everything you do as a seal yeah that
every thing that you do your cleaning
stuff your bone stuff up you're setting
stuff on fire you're shooting guns with
lead and it's just a disaster for your
lungs yeah and so you know really the
only potentially logical explanation as
a basic you know buds instructor and so
bro the the Master Chief that was I was
working for at the time you know camp
can't say enough good things about him
he hooked me up and made a deal with it
with the training Master Chief and they
sent me over there and I spent you know
three years there which you know was an
amazing experience too and and Ayana say
I've drawn a lot of lessons from being
an instructor to both life and to
training dogs which I know we'll get
into but you know so it was neat to be
behind the curtain there for a little
while and see see what the Wizards
awesome speak but you know then when I
like I said I as I was there I started
that's when the West Coast canine
program was coming up online
Oh 708 timeframe and and I went and did
did some decoy training with some of
their guys up at a vendor they were
using up in Cal and Central California
and it's almost kind of like a working
interview basically if hey is this
something you want to get involved with
and I was like yeah absolutely and so
they basically I was had a crossroads
they said you know if if you want a
reenlist and whatever you know you can
come come be a handler here you know or
that's it you know and I thought about
it for a while and for me you know it's
one of those Forks in the road that
there isn't a right answer you know I
wouldn't be where I'm at today but I'd
be I'd be lying if I said there isn't
part of me that wishes I had stayed in
I'd still be in doing deployments as a
handler I'm sure you know so but for me
again just kind of back to like when I
first joined the Navy I've always looked
at it is how can I make a bigger impact
not not what do I want most personally
but what what's gonna make more of an
impact in terms of the industry and
helping more people
to me it just made sense if I can sell
you know lots of dogs and and provide
handler training and run courses and
source nice dogs to feed the program and
all that then then that makes more sense
from a big picture standpoint did you
ever get connected with any of the
vietnam-era dog handlers I did a team
guy actually yeah do you ever hear
stories about Prince Prince oh yeah some
Prince was like the the I I believe was
the most successfully used dog in
Vietnam by the seals dog named Prince I
I heard stories when I first got in
about Prince and one of the stories that
I heard and again this is the story of
it's an oral tradition that's been
passed down but the story was that there
was guys that were getting extracted on
a helicopter and that they all piled it
was a hot extract there all the guys
pile into the bird and they've got
Prince the dog with them and the guy
says you know hey we're too heavy to
take off somebody's got to get out and
this is the air crewmen looks at you
know looks at the chief and says hey
we're too heavy to take off somebody's
got to get out and looks at the guy and
looks at Prince like get the dog out of
here we got to take off and the story
goes that the handlers SEAL handler like
put his hand on on the dog and was like
none of us are going anywhere and they
had to just crank the engines and you
know barely be able to take off but that
was the that was the the story that I
heard about and there's pictures of
Prince you can see in the archives so I
just wondered if you ever talked to any
of the guys that weren't any the Prince
handlers no not not that I'm aware of
there's there's a guy and and you know I
actually never talked him about what his
dog's name was I'm sure if it was him he
probably would have told me but there
was one I think he was the first Vietnam
Seal k-9 handler that I talked to right
as my first book came out and sent him a
signed copy and you know talked to him a
little bit as it was as it was coming
out which was for me just it was an
awesome experience being like hearing
this guy talk like he was basically like
here's a dog figure it out you know I
mean that's about the gist of it
apparently they had some hard times the
firt they didn't know what they were
doing yeah they took a couple
deployments
before they figured out okay and they
got the dog prints up to speed and
apparently he saved a bunch of guys
overtime yeah I mean he added some
pretty interesting things to say about
the program and the efficacy of the dogs
back then and and yeah I mean a lot of
it was them just kind of working their
way through it and that's the thing that
that I think most people probably
there's probably the biggest
misrepresentation of canine programs is
that it's not a weapon system you know
where it's like okay you're mark one
motto team guy like you'll figure it out
like it's a totally different animal no
pun intended it is I mean like you know
the the podcast she did with with the
sax right when he's talking about horses
takes ten years no it's it's that way
with dogs really is I mean because it's
it's a totally different deal it takes
years to get truly you know I would say
to be able to master you know what it
takes to implement a dog program it's
it's akin to flipping on a another
detachment you know we're saying hey
we're gonna create a female special
forces you know like it's gonna take a
long time before that that's up and
running and dog programs are very
similar that way so it's hard enough
when you've got training cadre resources
you know budgeting building all that
stuff in your favorite still takes
several years you know to just say
here's a dog figure it out like Matt
that's a that's a tough pill to swallow
yeah those guys did it you know just
like it's just like any of us would you
know I will figure it out but well
alright let's let's let's get into the
book a little bit cuz I think that'll
just guide us because I had a great time
reading this book as you know I have a
dog as well which is man later yeah see
but the book that I decided to go with
you got three books out obviously that
the the SEAL team dog is a book more
it's a what they call in the in the
literary industry it's a why a book for
young adults right that's what it is but
yeah it's it's actually Navy SEAL dogs
is the young adult adaptation of
training so it's the same same same dog
so don't buy that one if you're an adult
don't get moldable yeah don't get both
of them but then this book team dog how
to train your dog the Navy SEAL way and
what the reason and he soon as you got
here today you're like you know I just
got listen to the last podcast with the
sax and there's so many parallels
you'd be surprised and I was like like
are we gonna talk about that I'm like of
course we are that's there's so many
parallels between how you lead a dog and
how you lead a human as awful as that
might sound it's absolutely true one of
the things you kick off here and and I
kind of skip to the middle of the book
because it's talking about selection so
I'm gonna go to the book here selection
is crucial I can't emphasize this poison
point enough in most cases when I've
been asked to intervene in problem dog
situations what I instantly see is a
Mitch map mismatch such as either a
slightly built person or an elderly
couple who have a 75-pound high-energy
dog who they can't walk without being
dragged along those people are
physically incapable of exerting enough
force to stop that dog for moving a
necessary first step in getting a dog to
walk properly on a leash that's just one
example of how better selection could
have resulted in a better relationship
and again you that's a real obvious one
that's one of the easiest ones
understand oh I'm a small old woman and
I can't get a hundred pound dog to drag
me around but there's a lot of a lot of
other characteristics that are way more
nuanced for instance a dog that is super
high-energy and you're a working person
that's busy all the time you got to work
on your home and you're gonna have that
dog nipping at you all the time play
with me play with me play with me play
with me that's not gonna be a good match
that's not gonna be a good match at all
and and you see well you were quoting
some of the quotes about I mean tell me
a little bit about dog ownership in
America right now because I think a lot
of it selection has a lot to do with
where we end up with problems so there's
two things really I mean dog ownership
as a whole is it's a goatrope honestly
and that's where this book stems from
that's where my my team dog online
training program stems from and frankly
the the campaign that I'm about to
launch that that is in essence the crux
of the problem with with dog ownership
in this country is that it's it's
mismatched poor selection and most
importantly it's just an inability to
communicate properly with the dog and
and and what that stems from is very
simply is that you know dogs minds
the if you think about it from from the
most basic standpoint you can is that
you know you you know we're having this
conversation verbally right you dream in
a language you're talking a language you
think in a language we communicate
overwhelmingly verbally now when you
think about about dogs is that just
something as simple as you and I meeting
if if I come over I shake your hand and
we smile and nod I you know touch your
shoulder or whatever walk away if
somebody can see that from across the
parking lot and know that was a cordial
cordial greeting you and I stand up next
to each other and we're looking each
other like this and doing this kind of
stuff and sizing each other up and turn
around again from across the parking lot
you know those two dudes are about to
brawl now if it's that easy for us as
human beings who are overwhelmingly
verbal and how we communicate to pick
that thing up now imagine a dog who's
never thought in a language who doesn't
dream in a language doesn't communicate
in a language now now think about how
important body language and nonverbal
communication skills are it's everything
to a dog and so their their mind is an
algorithm it works like a calculator it
doesn't work like like our minds and
that's that's the biggest single crucial
element where people make the mistakes
as they anthropomorphize and they attach
all these human associations emotions
logic and reasoning to a dog's brain and
it doesn't work that way you know the a
plus B equals C you know the scientific
jargon is antecedent plus behavior
equals consequence but just think of it
like a calculator is that grabbing the
leash plus putting it on you know
grabbing the leash a plus putting it on
B equals we go for a walk see when a
plus B is paired enough times to where
dog anticipate C that's when you have
problems how many people have you seen
you know they have a dog that they grab
the leash and he's just you know
spinning around the moon and they can't
even get a leash on him to take him for
a walk let alone settle down that's why
is because every single time you've
paired a plus B it's equaled C and now
he's anticipating when a and he's
anticipating C when a and B are present
so something as simple as breaking that
context gets rid of that you know a lot
of people let's put a prong collar on it
was put a knee Kyle it's an iam and the
ribs let's manhandle them all these
things all you have to do is break that
contact
you know and it's really that simple is
it whether you're trying to build it or
whether you're trying to break it the
process is the exact same you're gonna
make a plus B equals C enough times to
where you want them to anticipate it or
if C is something you don't want
anticipated you're gonna make a plus B
not equal it so with the leash example
its I go grab the leash I click it I
wrap it around my waist I go sit down on
the couch with it and now the dogs
looking at you like his mind's blown
he's like what the hell is going on
we're supposed to be walking right now
and then I get up I put it back and I go
sit down and go about my day you do that
enough times and now when you grab the
leash doesn't mean anything to them so
just as one simple example if you think
about all of these different behaviors
that we as human beings inadvertently
create in the animal that that is why is
it's a it's a lack of that understanding
that their mind just works differently
than ours as soon as you understand that
coupled with presence you know I know
you have to speak about this in your in
your business leadership conferences in
how you carry yourself how you interact
with people is huge you know and if it's
again if it's that big with people I
mean you know you're the type of guy
that you know you walk in the room Peter
like this dude's running running the
show right a lot of people you know that
we've worked with or worked for are like
that just command respect by the way
they carry themselves by the way they
walk in and if it's again if it's that
effective just with us as human beings
who aren't driven that way primarily now
imagine a dog like I do exercises with
dogs all the times where I don't say a
word to them it'll be the first time
I've ever seen a dog I'll put up a
three-foot leash on them in a room with
basically nothing in it and this is a
dog that you know they've had all these
problems with it's a nine month old
crazy high-energy dog and I did it just
the other day actually on the trip I was
on before this this training facility
was having trouble with this dog and I
wanted to go to using some some
compulsion methods some some prong
collar an e-collar stuff to get the dog
under control I said let me let me mess
them for a minute so I I connect the
leash to him I walk around with a minute
just you know tugging on a leash and
feeling him you know getting a feel for
his personality but you know if you
think of it like like a bumper or a
buffer is that you're you're the buffer
between that dog his mind and
and the stimuli and everything that goes
between it you're almost the gatekeeper
and so when you you have to get inside
that dog's mind and be able to reach it
first you know which which means I have
to mirror what I want out of the dog if
he's a spaz I can't treat him like a
spaz I can't spaz out and yank him and
yell at him and get all up in his grill
about it I need to throttle it down and
and and be a mirror or a representation
a physical representation of what I want
out of him and so it got to the point
where I finally got him to just relax
lay down and I could get up and walk
around the room and he wouldn't move and
he had not done that before and it's not
it's not anything crazy magic wizard
stuff it's just it's a basic
understanding of canine psychology
operant conditioning and the four
quadrants but but most importantly it's
it's that nonverbal communication aspect
that what dogs is just imperative when
you another thing that before we move on
past selection or get a little bit more
but a lot of times people figure they
want certain breed of dog right and I
had a great conversation you with when I
was getting a dog a while back and you
were like look you could have a great
dog that's a month you could have a
great dog that's a purebred whatever you
name it you could have a horrible dog
that's a month and you can have a
horrible dog that's a purebred whatever
you want to name it or whatever that
breed is it there's the the the the
breed that you get obviously you got to
look at how big it's gonna be and what
kind of temperament but the temperament
thing how how well is that temperament
thing and how much how much impact is
that there's the breed and the
temperament align so I would say that
there's there's basically two categories
there's the working varieties in the
non-working varieties when it comes to
non-working varieties in other words
your average domesticated house pet
honestly it's it's a paint job and in my
opinion you know breed really is what do
you like what do you like what what does
it look like and then what do you like
it's purely aesthetic or almost that way
because they are bred for aesthetics are
not bred for working working traits
known you're talking about now in law
Shepherds Catahoula x' [ __ ] dogs you
know terrier types rat terriers patter
dales what
or any type of dog does bred
purposefully now it is a different
ballgame now I would say that you know
most mountain was as an example you know
do have a higher level of energy a
higher Drive that doesn't necessarily
translate to good Drive you know a lot
of people make the the misconception
that no my dog has tons of energy he
just needs a job he needs to work and
he'd be a great working dog not
necessarily you know it could be nervous
energy it could be anxiousness could be
thin environmental nerves there's a lot
of different reasons but back to your
question is that from a selection
standpoint you know the if you're
talking about any breed that you're just
getting it's an AKC dog or even a
shelter dog or whatever that's that's
not bred from three four or five
generations of lineage that's that's
been selected because it brings certain
working traits to the table it's a good
dog is where you find it you know it
really is mean it's it's what other
parents like if it's out of a shelter
just go evaluate the dog with the same
tips that I gave you their honest saying
and I do that I don't care where the
dogs coming from it could be the best
bred dog from the most pipe hitter ish
parents I've ever come across I'm still
gonna evaluate that dog with with zero
kennel blinded miss with no bias
whatsoever I don't care if it's a friend
of mine I don't care if it's puppies I
raised I I wash out puppies that I breed
and raise all the time because they're
just not what I need and that's from a
selection standpoint to tie in the SEAL
Teams and having been an instructor the
reason I think that now I think the
reason that that the caliber of
individual that shows up at a SEAL team
is is so high is because Budds is such a
tough selection process I asked the
other day like people asked me what you
know did you learn how to deal with
stress did you learn in buds and I'm
like no you don't actually learn that
you just if you can't you go away they
don't there's not a class where they say
okay when you start feeling stressed
here's what you do or when you start
feeling like you can't go any further we
want you to repeat this mantra no no
they don't do that they just put you in
crappy situations and if you want to
quit you quit there's no education no I
think the only education exists is you
learn who you are yeah that's that's a
good point yeah but no one teaches you
know I mean it's this I guess I guess
the environment is what teaches you that
another good thing you wrote in here and
you just talked about a little bit dogs
are meant to be active and are happiest
when they're doing something and the
reason I highlighted that was because
it's the same thing with people it's the
same thing I've been talking about with
Joe Rogan it's the same thing I've been
talking about with Jordan Peterson you
know with Joe Rogan we're saying that
you know you need some kind of a
struggle to make you feel like you're
accomplishing something with Jordan
Peterson it's you know we talked about
how if you take up the burden of
responsibility that's what gives you a
purpose and so for dogs if you're just
gonna let your dog run around do
whatever he wants well he's not really
going to be happy is that the point it
is and and here's a I would say a
classic example of us as humans
anthropomorphizing certain elements to
dogs by that I mean that we we look at
it as a job as purpose right again this
is my opinion I'm not a world-renowned
canine psychologist but but I play one
on TV but you know the fact is is that
you know dogs I don't think have that
that depth of understanding of purpose
they have what I would I would classify
it as you know like a five-year-old is
they have a need to be stimulated
physically mentally emotionally socially
nutritionally everything just like we as
human beings and where you see problems
and I see it all the time with with my
online dog training is that you know
when people first start out that it's
it's kind of a reeducation of sorts of
of saying you know number one you've got
to put yourself in the dog's shoes and
I'm gonna help you doing it by
structuring these these monthly lessons
so that they're cumulative so that you
you can understand and watch your dog
transform and then learn from it but
what it is is that it's it's making an
understanding is just like with people
is that you know that dog needs to have
physical exercise as part of his daily
regimen he needs to have routine so that
so that he can count on you and and and
depend on you for providing the
resources that necessitates his life
he's got to have mental stimulation just
like we do I mean you can do nothing but
work out but think about the difference
between a gym workout and a jiu-jitsu
role in terms of what it does for your
mind like it's night and day difference
and so you can't just go make your dog
blow his physical wad every day playing
ball like you you've got to make his
mind work and that's where using
clicker to reinforce and shape behaviors
comes into play because now they have to
think they have to figure things out and
it is it's it's it's mentally exhausting
or at a minimum stimulating and they
require that same with food same with
sunlight you know is that if imagine you
sit in here
you know 23 hours a day or you don't go
outside you don't roll you eat beef
jerky and canned goods or McDonald's you
know do that week after week after week
where are you gonna be you know across
the board physically mentally
health-wise immune system everything's
gonna be garbage and so what happens is
a lot of these people they they think
there's you know spoiling their dog I
don't know when that became a positive
thing but but you know they think that
you know by not making him do things not
teaching him things not enforcing things
not having a routine in which that dog
can depend on not stimulating his mind
not making sure that he's physically
active in keeping him in good shape that
those are all benefits and they're not
the detriments you know needless to say
this applies directly to your kids and
how you're raised together just
everything you just rattled off it's
basically how you end up with spoiled
kids that are lazy and unproductive in
their lives 100% and and by the way lazy
unproductive and unhappy because they're
not gonna be happy when they're a loser
sitting around playing video games you
know 23 hours a day covered in cheeto
dust that's my favorite the you know one
of the things that I think that is
really interesting to me of how dog
training kind of relates to life is that
it's it's it's like a petri dish or
almost a a microcosm of life is that
no different than whether it's business
relationship goals leadership a coach
with his athletes a teacher with
students a parent with their kids you
name it but you know a general with his
troops is that you have to have an
objective you got to know what how do I
want my dog you know what does a finish
dog look like you got to know in your
mind what is that just like you want to
be a black belt in jujitsu you want to
own a ten million dollar company
whatever it is if you don't know where
you want to go
you're not gonna steer it anywhere
you're gonna be floating around so you
gotta know that first then you got to be
honest with yourself in terms of doing
an evaluation where am i okay now I know
where I want to be I know we're on that
now it's formulating a plan and then you
schedule it and execute it just
like every other aspect to your life
there is honestly no difference the neat
thing about dog training is that you
know you can go through that process
dozens of times you know as a dog
trainer especially but even if you just
have a dog that that it's a condensed
process that's that's in a such a
controlled environment you see the cause
and effect you see that the criteria
driven algorithmic process that exists
in all of life but it plays out and
you're manipulating it you're
controlling it you're directly
influencing every aspect of it and so
I've learned more about people by
training dogs and I would have ever
imagined and you know I mean it's it's
mind-numbing almost how much you can you
can learn from training dogs and how to
interact with people based on on all
that you know it it's it's pretty pretty
fascinating I think ya know there's no
doubt I got that all out of this book
too going on to what you talked about a
little bit but just to clarify what you
specifically wrote in the book here you
talked about meeting a dog before we get
into the specifics of that process I
want to take a moment to turn this
discussion around again and focus on you
and not the dog if a dog is looking for
someone to take charge and exert
authority over him in order to not
burden him with that responsibility then
you need to carry yourself a certain way
I go back to something I said in the
introduction about wanting to be
respected over being liked think about
the kinds of introductions and greetings
you've had with people and a variety of
ways in which they've interacted with
you how would you respond if you met
someone for the first time and they
rushed up to you hugged you tapped us
a-- your hair jumped up and down and
generally acted like you were the
greatest person on the face of the earth
wouldn't you think that or would you
think that person's assessment of you
was valid would you like that kind of
physical contact would you think that
this was a great starting point for a
long-term relationship would you have
respect for that person and then you get
to this point where you say what kind of
dog is going to be attracted to that
kind of greeting and that message and
the answer is a needy dog yeah that's an
incredible point yeah you know we do you
really want you know let's say you're
hiring an employee and the employee you
can tell just needs a lot of
encouragement even though
all fired up but the more you fire them
up the more fired up they get well is
that the person you really want to have
that's gonna take you there to get
emotionally prod them along to get them
where you want to go the answer is
obviously no yeah you know one of the
one of the most common kind of scenario
analogies that I throw at people when
because you know I do a lot of speaking
and events and conferences and whatever
and you know one of the almost always
offline people I call my dog I need to
send them to him like that's not gonna
fix it you know no different than you
send me your kids like they're gonna
work well for me not gonna work well for
you because you're not not doing it but
but think of it from a perspective from
a boardroom is that you know when they
say my dog doesn't respect me there's
two things there's a big difference
between respecting and enjoying or
liking so the first first example I use
is the you know being at a bar and I'll
save the the heavy details but the gist
of it is that if if the opposite sex is
throwing themselves at you do you like
that well yeah do you enjoy it
absolutely do you respect that person no
you know so you can spoil your dog you
can let him sleep let him sleep in my
bed I take him for walks I give him
treats I take him to acupuncture and
just he doesn't listen to me like I bet
your kids don't either and that's why
because it's it's the it's the 19 year
old at the bar that's trying to flatter
you that doesn't it's enjoyable but it
doesn't doesn't garner respect the
second thing on a more serious note is
think of a boardroom and I use this
because I talk with a lot of business
folks and things different events and
let's say that you're tasked with going
in front of the the 12 executives of the
company you work for and and your boss
says hey you're gonna give a PowerPoint
presentation and your job depends on
this if you knock it out of the park
you're getting a promotion you're gonna
be an executive if it doesn't go that
well well you're gonna pack your stuff
and find find employment elsewhere now I
want you to think about how you go into
that boardroom right and I want you to
think about visualize in your mind
interacting with those 12 executives the
way that you interact with your dog
how would that how would that
presentation go you know every one of
them I'd get laughed out of the room
that's why your dog doesn't listen to
you because your dog you you can tell
your dog that you're his owner all you
want you have to show him that if he
doesn't believe you because you
haven't shown him that guess what you're
not you can think about it and you can
wish that you were you can hope that you
were the fact is is that your dog is
going to believe who you show him that
you are and if that's a clown
guess what he thinks you're a clown if
you're an emotionally unstable you know
Jay a that's how it's how he's going to
view you if you're a beta male because
you're rolling around and letting him
you know do whatever he wants to you
he's gonna view you as such you know and
the most dangerous combination there's a
lot of times you hear the word dominance
get thrown around alpha and all this
other stuff I can tell you I can count
on one hand the amount of dogs that I've
come across that were truly what I would
consider an alpha dog and this is a dog
that even with all my experience all of
the manipulations I can provide in terms
of setting the environment up to to make
it so that I'll you know impact him that
way he still wants to fight me over
everything no matter what I do and I
can't get in his head no matter how hard
I try no matter what I do physically
mentally environmental manipulation you
name it less than five what was out of
thousands of thousands of thousands of
thousands in five that actually will
need to be the alpha male over you with
everything that you know how to get in
their head that no matter what you do
with them they still look at at
everybody like you're below me a handful
of them you know less than a handful of
them and so when I hear especially pet
owners like oh he's really alpha he's
really protective and no he's not
what it is they're just weak there's a
power vacuum yeah and and so you know
dogs again they don't rationalize I
don't have the logic and reasoning we
have they become hardwired with a set of
genetically inherited traits that say if
there is no nothing in charge if there's
a vacuum whether I want to do it or not
I'm going to because somebody has to and
so when you see all of these dogs that
are dangerous and guarding of food and
and territorial and all this other stuff
you have a dog that doesn't want to be
in charge but is taking that role
because nobody else will and that is a
absolute recipe for disaster and that's
why you see so many problems with with
dogs and their owners is because of that
simple fact and
itself yeah you talking you know again
we're talking about all these
similarities here's here's the thing you
got in the book encouraging that kind of
over-the-top display of affection is the
complete opposite of how you should
present yourself to an unfamiliar pup or
dog you were the one who is making the
decision you are the one in charge and
how you carry yourself into the
situation and what signals your body
language sends are something that any
dog will recognize and decode
immediately do you want to concede the
position of power in that relationship
immediately absolutely not and again
this is the same thing as a leader now
this doesn't mean you point this out in
the book this doesn't mean that you
dominate this doesn't mean that you come
in and you're you're overly aggressive
and I talk about that all the time with
being a leader this doesn't mean that
you come in and you're barking orders at
people because that doesn't work either
that that so you got to find that
balance just like you do with with
humans sure there's a couple things with
that again with dogs especially because
it's it's so simplified you know that
that element is reduced to a very primal
nature you know so when you have a dog
that truly is dominant if you display
that guess what you're getting in a
fight if you have a dog that's not that
way and you display that what happens
the dog is scared when the dog is scared
of you no different than if you you know
have have a child that's you know at the
third grade level you know when they
walk into a classroom or they're sitting
in a classroom and the teacher walks in
and they blow their anal glands you know
because they're they're getting ready to
get whipped with rulers and you know
electrocuted or god knows what else
they're not gonna learn anything on a
transverse if when you walk in there
throwing spit wads and playing tag and
ignore you entirely they're not gonna
learn anything area there either so just
like in all walks of life there's
balance but what what it is is it's
exactly that it's it's maintaining a
level of of emotional stability a calm
demeanor and and arrested but calculated
mind in terms of how you interact with
that animal and it's it's really it's
not hard at all there there's two videos
that I in my online thing called be the
man be the man part one and be the man
part two where I do exactly that I don't
say really a word in essence to two
different dogs both very strong very
dominant dogs that it you know their
their level of prey drive for a toy a
ball
have you is such that if I have it they
just you know they start shaking and
barking and bouncing and they'll try to
take it from even though they're both
personal dogs of mine in the past their
drive is so overblown and over driven
that it overrides everything common
sense wise and you actually can't use
that to train them because it's it's so
so over driven but some people are all
excited about prey Drive but you can
have too much prey drive if you're not
balanced I would say that it's to me
that I would say no there's no such
thing in my opinion for the dogs I work
with I would say there's no such thing
as too much there is too much to do
certain types of training or that if I'm
trying to teach obedience focus stuff
like that no I won't use balls and toys
like that because it is too much I'll
use food or body language now when it
comes to controlling impulse and things
like that yeah absolutely but it's after
I've done enough repetitions to where it
transfers from being a decision to a
reaction no different but you can end up
can you end up with a dog that's his
prey Drive is so high that he you can't
take him to the park and trust that he's
going to what can you train it out a
clean train well you can control it you
can cap that Drive by reinforcing it so
think of it this way and this is the
more drive and lack of impulse control
that dogs have the more you know energy
etc all the things that typically win
dogs up in shelters all of those those
components are something that can that
can absolutely be controlled but the
thing to remember is that think about
the first fistfight you were ever in or
even if it happens now think about where
your mind is at it's at a very elevated
state just like when you see an amateur
fight or the first couple fights like
you know they're just going in for the
fences they blow their wad they you know
whereas you see a guy that's calculated
that's been doing it a while he knows
how to control that that's that's what
in essence what you're teaching the dog
but you have to do it they can't
rationalize that the way you do it is
the exact same though is that you're
putting them through so many repetitions
no different than think about the very
first time you were on your primary and
you pull the trigger and nothing
happened you had to think okay I'm gonna
put it down and trigger control and
you're doing all the things in your head
at a certain point that becomes a
reaction or when that becomes a reaction
then you're trained same thing with the
dog is that you've got to do those
repetitions using things to reinforce it
if
the dog is in that state of mind because
the key component is you got to do it
when they're not in that state of mind
to be able to control them when they're
in that state of mind you have to build
that foundation first just you know you
can't you can't teach a fighter how to
be composed by doing real real matches
that comes in training and so it the the
parallel again is exact is that you've
got to you've got to use a classroom and
what I do I use a 40 by 40 classroom
where I use a clicker food treats
affection body language and I and I
teach and shape all these behaviors that
I'm trying to teach until it becomes a
reaction and then I just slowly start to
introduce distractions and graduate them
K through 12 until they're until they're
doctors you know of going out and some
of the videos I have of some of the dogs
I've worked with you know and and one of
them is a black German Shepherd actually
just sold them to a big Metroplex
SWAT team but I could take him through
Walmart off leash I could take him to
parks where kids are playing soccer
around him and this is a dog that even
if I have a ball he'll bite through my
hand to get to it and I could get to
wear without using any punishment
without using any compulsion just by
doing shaping and reinforcing and using
you know that a + b CH will see over and
over until it became a conditioned
response and now the dog works on
autopilot but it's like your name you
know when somebody says Jocko you know
how to think about responding you've
heard it enough times to do that you
know same same exact print principle
what's up with resource guarding usually
what it stems from is is it again an
inadvertent creative created behavior
kids messing with them taking food from
them a lot of times you know see people
I want to be able to take food I don't
mess with the dogs when they eat now I
need to be able to bump them walk by
them take it from them if I have to but
it's it's when a dog has really high
Drive for something and you compete for
that over and over and over you're
building think of it like a barrier in
the dog's mind and you've got a your
goal is to kind of hit the refresh
button on the computer screen and that
dog is mine and so you know what I'll do
like if a dog has real heavy resource
guarding with with food as an example is
that now I'll feed that dog his entire
ration of food from my
and throughout the day training so now
it's not me setting a bowl of food down
and now you're gonna guard it and get
get crappy with me it's you know when
you do what I want then you're gonna
market and reward it you're getting it
from my hand and it just breaks that
context wide open and now it now it
doesn't become a thing in the police dog
realm one of the one of the most common
examples of of that behavior misfiring
is is outing you know when we're doing
bite work and that dog isn't that's
crazy elevated state of mind and he's
Jenni's over lapping prey and defensive
drive and you're transferring back and
forth is it now you say okay let go just
like the first time you got in a fight
like you know one of your buddies taps
you on the shoulder hey stop fighting
like you don't hear that so to reach
that dog's mind when they're in that
elevated stated it all boils down to you
got to enter their mind first to
communicate but is it when they're in
that elevated state in mind what what
usually happens is they use an e-collar
prong collar they grab their the dogs
flat collar the roll it twist it and
just like a guillotine choke and lift
them off all that does is create
conflict between the handler and end dog
and it and it builds and creates
possession over objects so with a ball
you see it all the time people my dog
won't give me the ball how do I get it
from what are you doing and you're
watching he's chasing the guy he's
chasing the dog around with the ball how
do I get him to let go of the ball get
another ball make your ball sexier than
the ball that he has the second he drops
it you mark it and throw the new ball
just like that now the dog will spit it
out for you with no conflict with no no
problems whatsoever but it's that way
with everything it's with food it's with
toys it's with your name you talked a
lot about indifference in here as sort
of a I don't know is like a base sort of
reaction to a lot of stuff and I noticed
that with my dog if I want my dog to
drop a ball if I just ignore him for for
five seconds the ball drops out and then
he looks at me because he knows it's
like okay can you can you pay some
attention cuz I want you to fill this
thing again boom bend down grab the ball
throw it again he comes back he wants to
he wants to fight for it but if I ignore
him just just look away for three
seconds yeah ball gets dropped then down
take it yeah man it's the same it's the
same barroom psychology why aren't you
paying attention to me yeah but you know
to bring it back to the dog aspect is
that you know if
think about it from from more of a
almost a primal nature of think about
kids when you watch kids what's what's a
very natural when you bring several kids
together what do they do naturally they
chase each other it's a natural function
in animals on the planet dogs are no
different so if they have something it's
a game as much as anything but you can
you can turn it into something more
serious as the dog gets older and they
become more possessive and driven
because you've built those barriers in
their mind but in terms of the
indifference piece 100% the the one of
the first things I do with the warrior
dog foundation the nonprofit that that I
have that we retire you know former
SpecOps dogs and police dogs and
contract working dogs and all sorts of
different dogs but the very first thing
I do with all those dogs is I have a
pouch of food I have a clicker and the
clicker just for those of you that you
know too so that you understand what I'm
talking about it's just a little
mechanical device it has a button on it
pushing it goes it just makes a very
mechanical sound that's unique that
pairs whatever the behavior is with a
reward it's it's a bridging of stimulus
so just think about it like taking a
picture you know is that you're letting
the dog know that the the instant of
what's taking place right this second is
correct and a reward is attached to that
but anyway so I let him out of the gate
and I've got a two and a half acre
training field around my kennel facility
and so it's just me and the dog walking
around with a pouch full of food and a
clicker yeah and I I completely ignore
him and I purposely walk away from them
and anytime that dog comes over to me I
mark it reward it turn around and walk
away from them again and I'll do that
for five to ten minutes three four times
a day for a few days and I mean we've
taken in over 80 dogs over the last
eight years seven and a half eight years
and to this day there's not been a dog
yet where where that has not worked and
I've done it with a lot of other dogs
too but is that even if they hate people
you know their defensive aggressive
they're environmentally rattled their
pts type issues what have you is that
that that element of you getting paid
and in me shaping certain behaviors
works on on all of them but it works the
same way with people you know that's one
of the things in terms of something like
the leadership stuff that you do is that
is that operant condition a positive
reinforcement you know the four
quadrants while yes I work primarily in
the
in the positive reinforcement realm I do
use positive punishment I use negative
reinforcement negative punishment but
for for the layman think of it from you
know if you're your spouse is out of
town and you spend the weekend cleaning
the entire house right it's spotless
you know kids are all in check you know
the old lady comes home and the house is
spotless the very first thing that she
recognizes is that the one thing you
didn't do was take the trash out and
that's the first thing she's like you
didn't take the trash out like I guess
I'll have to do that you know that like
that's her response how likely are you
to clean the house ever again very not
likely not likely
whereas you know on the transverse if
you know she grabs ahold and whatever
you know or give you some positive
reinforcer you some positive
reinforcement maybe in another room then
then you know that that speaks for
itself you know so it's that same
element and don't call me mr. clean
around here I don't have to pick your
head yeah you'll be cleaning the house
every weekend you know so it's it's just
it's it's a very simple element of you
know one of the analogies you could use
too is it's the difference between slave
labor and a job with great benefits you
know at the end of the day a task is
being performed but one you know the
level of drive motivation satisfaction
happiness on one end there too you know
180-degree bipolar or despair at
opposites so you know just it's just
basic reinforcement but if you look at
everything a dog does in that in that
regard and that you know every every
time that they do something that you
want it gets marked and reinforced every
time that you they do something you
don't want it gets extinguished and or
corrected it's very black and white
another quick example is a toys in the
house you don't like my dogs chewing
this up to and out up do you keep toys
in the house oh yeah he's got Kong's and
other balls and stuff my rule of thumb
and my advice to everybody is make it
black and white and the dogs my again he
doesn't know the difference between a
tennis shoe a stuffed animal a Kong
whatever it's all crap that's laying
around your floor you know can you make
them distinguish things yeah but let's
not put the cart before the horse I'll
teach him to respect what you say first
and so he doesn't get to play with
anything
in the house if he knows that nothing
gets in his mouth inside the house other
than what I hand him then it's real easy
to teach him don't chew on stuff it's
outside it's in a crate it's in a kennel
that's when I'll give you things to play
with to chew it to tug with whatever and
build that engagement work on the bond
in relationship or whatever but you have
in here when I see so-called problem
dogs the problem stems from an imbalance
of power and relationship and not from
the dog so that's that's like the root
that you see all the time the person's
weak we have pretty much already talked
about that and it's the same thing you
see a lot with leadership where you've
got someone that's that there's an
imbalance of power and and but where it
gets more complicated with humans as
humans then do their own kind of self
correct and a lot of times they over
correctly under correct you know if
they're being too if they're being too
micromanaging then they go all the way
the other side of total laissez-faire
and now people don't know what to do or
if they're being too laissez-faire then
they go straight to level 12
micromanagement and again it's just it's
just a personality thing or a mistake
that they're making and it imbalances
the relationship that we have with you
because it's like yeah I want you to
tell me something to do I want you to
give me some guidance I just don't want
nothing and and people lose that here's
another one it's important to establish
your authority over a dog dogs want need
and seek that kind of presence in their
lives you just hammer this over and over
again it's easy in some respects to get
a dog to fear you but it can be equally
easy to get a dog to respect you just as
true with human relationships a dog will
have more respect for you if you make it
clear that good behavior gets rewarded
and poor behavior has consequences you
may have noticed I have not used the
word like or love up into this point in
describing the human canine relationship
that is not an accidental omission I've
purposely not used those words because
too far often I encounter people whose
immediate response to a dog's to try and
get the animal to like them in doing so
they make fools of themselves and dog
eyes possibly put themselves in danger
because they assume that they know that
how they treat their dog is okay with a
different dog and mistakenly believe
that because of all the nice things they
do for their pet their dog should obey
their wishes and in design
unconditionally if you take one concept
away from this from this beginning part
of the book it's this don't mistake
liking for respect and don't mistake
obedience for trust we could be talking
about human beings right there clearly
especially kids you know oh absolutely
kids and employees yeah because it's
it's not a popularity contest
yeah and and that's where so many
parents and administrators or coaches or
supervisors etc go go wildly wrong is
worrying what somebody thinks about them
you know and again I mean it's them to
draw back to the microcosm of the dog
training process is that you know what's
the end goal getting your kids or your
employees or whatever it is to think
you're cool isn't part of the process
you know it has no no relevance well I
mean it has no no productive
productivity yeah and and what's
interesting about life life used to run
the Java C course the junior officer
training course which is the guys that
the young officers coming out of buds
and there was an officer this is the
other end of the spectrum there's an
officer that would come in to talk and
eventually they've had it like back the
guy tactically out of the schedule
because he would say if you're an
officer and your men like you you're
doing a bad job that's not what we're
talking about here you know it's not
that you don't it's nothing you want
your dog to aggressively hate you and
you don't want your employees to think
this guy doesn't care about me in fact I
talked about this a little while ago
like the more you the more you care
about your people the more they'll care
about you the better performance they
deliver right if they don't think you
care about them well then they're not
gonna deliver any kind of a performance
other than the absolute minimum that's
required yeah well and and you know from
from the dog perspective that's where
you know the there is a little bit of a
difference in that with dogs it's about
engagement you know one of the one of
the examples I use is you know how many
times have you been to a park right and
you see there's it's usually dad's but
you know there's the dad sitting on the
bench on his phone and his kids are
swinging and playing tag whatever and
he's oblivious like they could get
kidnapped and they wouldn't know any
better
unfortunately whereas that dad that's
pushing them that's playing tag chasing
them around grab
with him all that kind of stuff now when
he goes back hey honey would you do I
took the kids to the park but those are
two disparately different experiences
now you think about from the perception
of where the kids are at the difference
like it's night and day same thing with
a dog you know and that's one of the
things I'm so adamantly against dog
parks dog parks are the iPads to to dogs
what what iPads are to kids you know you
can't have a substitute for that
engagement with them you know you can't
outsource your relationship and that and
that happens way way too often you know
again whether it's with kids amid you
know with dogs whatever like you know
there is an element of just like with
anything is that you know there's you
know training franchises that I'm
actually planning on launching here
later this year to help with that
process but it is it's an augment you
know and there is no substitute for for
what you have with with your dog with
your spouse with your children whatever
there's there's nobody that's gonna be
able to make that work for you if you
don't want it just like somebody comes
and make me a good good Jiu Jitsu artist
like you gotta want it first like you
got to be willing to put the time in
yeah I have with dogs it's no different
to that point
here's back to the book the bottom line
is that if your dog isn't doing what he
is supposed to or what you want him to
it's not the dog's fault
it's your fault accountability it's your
fault for not spending the time needed
to train him properly
we're not being observing the servant
enough to recognize early on when and
how your relationship may be out of
balance
many people are too lazy to achieve the
results they want if having a
spectacular relationship with your dog
we're super easy everyone would have a
have that and I wouldn't be running this
book right now one common excuse I hear
all the time is I don't have time well I
can assure you you do have the time what
you don't have is your priorities in the
order they need to be to have a great
relationship with your dog this is a
little bit of extreme ownership for your
dog and something we say all the time
you your team's not doing a good job
whose fault is it it's your fault you're
the boss that's whose fault it is yeah
yeah I mean and what I would hope is
that the the people that read that read
that that you know that you can take
that that self-evaluations here
you know and again i mean when i when i
read extremal ownership was like yes
it's textbook you know it's it's the
same same exact principles and that you
know if you're the one in charge guess
what you know if it's not going well it
doesn't work down yeah it's not trickle
trickle down responsibility you know it
goes straight to the top and that's
something I'm added but adamant about
with my employees is that you know if
you don't understand you were then
reason it's it's generally gonna be my
fault right you know if you don't
understand what you're supposed to do or
you know something happened that that
you weren't prepared for or whatever
then ultimately it's my bad you know
whether it's me putting the wrong person
in a position to experience that or me
not giving you the guidance prior to
putting you in that experience to be
able to deal with it
because with dogs it's dynamic you know
just like in the workplace you know
training people to work with some of
these dogs that we get in like I mean
it's it's no circus it is a circus but
it's no joke it can be a circus you know
but it's the same same type stuff you
know you talk about building
relationships here going back to the
book working or in my training of
working dogs I still put myself in the
dogs position and understand that it was
important to establish a positive
rapport with that animal before I began
making too many demands on them so this
is the the crux really of where I
wouldn't say you know nothing that
that's in this book or anything that I
subscribed to is not anything new you
know that I mean people have been have
domesticated animals for thousands of
years what I will say is that I
generally don't find people spending as
much time on that that simple component
as much as I do and this is where I draw
from my time with hard driven dominant
working dogs that are biting people when
you get in a bite suit and you're
working a dog and developing him no
different than you'd bring up young
fighters that that is what what a decoy
job is to do is to is to build
confidence and and with dogs you know
the nice thing is is that when it comes
to to aggression prey and defense are
two sides of the same coin you know just
like reproductive
reproduction and killing are two sides
of the same coin is that when I'm when
I'm in that suit and I'm reading that
dog I'm exuding all of these things on
him I'm either making him uncomfortable
and putting him in defensive drive and
then when he responds the way that I
want gives me you know aggressive
responds in kind with aggression I'd go
back into prey Drive take all that
pressure off and reward him coming
forward I'm teaching him to fight me and
and come forward Lee aggressive but the
the way that that I have been able to
develop that same strategy with pet dogs
is because when you're in a suit and
dealing with these dogs that are on a
level 12 out of ten by comparison the
pet dogs we deal with is that you know
you have to be so over overblown or so
dramatic with with how you're doing it
to be able to affect these dogs that now
when you're dealing with pet dogs it's
actually really easy but what what it
made me realize is just that same
concept it works the exact same way with
those dogs is that is that entering that
dog's mind and getting that relationship
first before you have that you are
completely wasting your time doing
anything else again no different than
you know if you're a boss with employees
or you know a military leader or pick
anything is that if there is a trust and
relationship there first as the
foundation you're you're building a
shanty on on sand you know in terms of
everything else you try to do that
without that you're essentially wasting
your time and so I hammer so hard on the
relationship component because it is
it's I mean that's a universal truth in
life ya know and it escalates to the
more you build that relationship the
more you can demand and of course in a
relationship you're not demanding from
people the more you build a relationship
you're more you can ask for someone to
give to you and the more they'll do for
you because you have a good relationship
with them for sure and there's there's
also a reason especially my online
training the the first five months
there's no corrections whatsoever
there's no punishment there's there's
nothing it's all bonding relationship
building and reinforcement shaping
behavior that's not by accident the
reason why is that a lot of times people
they don't have a relationship with a
dog that
getting into X or doing Y or whatever
let's put a prong collar a remote collar
on and let's punish him a lot of people
do that there's training franchises that
the the backbone is using remote collars
which I disagree with and it's not about
a cruelty thing it's about an
understanding is that if I have a great
relationship with that dog and again you
know the work environment whatever
spouse and then we've gone the the full
run of shaping and reinforcing desired
behaviors and I have clearly
communicated to him and positively
taught him what the expectations are now
when he's not performing up to that
standard now if I correct him and punish
him guess how much more effective it is
you know because at first it's you're
just you're just some other jerk that's
putting your knee in my rib cage or
electrocuting me or you know jerking me
off my feet with the prong collar just
like all the rest of them whereas now
it's like your dad saying I'm
disappointed in you but you know it's
it's it's it's a lot more impactful that
way you know so it means more dogs is
back to the book dogs respect confidence
power and authority and by dogs I mean
all dogs mm-hmm I don't care how much of
an alpha role any dog is assumed when
someone comes along who exhibits those
three traits to a greater degree than
they they will step aside with the
exception of the four the four that you
come across but you know those those are
dogs that I can assure you that nobody
on the and the 83 million dog owner pet
spectrum have ever run into you know
these are unicorns for sure would you do
with those dogs bred some of them one of
them was out on the west coast actually
as a working dog just retired you're not
not too long ago if I had to pick
probably the most gifted physically
across-the-board dog I've ever come
across it was a dog that was out there
for several years and that came in we
put him through his first handler course
and then he deployed and did several
deployments and just I mean he's a freak
you know a absolute freak but the first
years of funny story the first time I
met him so we're running our handler
course at Auburn University at their kin
detection Research Institute back when
it was still in in progress this was in
2011 we brought the dog in and we were
staying at a local hotel there and it's
a weak Handler course putting the dog
through and my very first introduction
to him is he was staying in the room
with his handler and they'd spent some
time together and had bought started the
bond and it was like a Holiday Inn
Express they had free pizza and so of
course I'm like I'm not gonna pass up
free pizza so I've got a paper plate
with couple pieces of pie on it and I
walk into the room the dog and just kind
of [ __ ] his head looks at me runs over
and literally like a dude like a team
guy jumps up and just bap just slaps it
right out of my hand and he leans down
and starts eating it and then I I
started to lean down he just looks up
and I've been around enough dogs where
like I was like you know I'm just gonna
let you eat that enjoy that be that
one's on me buddy and the first time I
saw our dogs working and I forget who
brought him out we were doing some
training and you know we it was set up
but the task and it was doing a hit in a
building and there was a guy that was
gonna run a decoy is gonna run and I was
out there and man when they so I see the
decoy go and you see the dog sees it and
the dog you you can feel it man this dog
is ready to murder this guy as if this
is just the most insane level of passion
and he's just on the end of that thing
and that you can see the handlers let
and let him blend a bill letting it
build let it build he pulls that quick
release bro I was like oh my god it was
insane to watch him fire off and he took
off like ten feet to when he finally got
like he's going a million miles an hour
across this field he takes off about ten
feet and just nails this guy dragged him
to the ground I was like okay this is a
good little system to implement here ya
know I mean from the neat thing about I
think capability wise is that it's you
know it's a it's a non-lethal form of
yeah of capture you know which is
obviously very valuable the deterrent
aspect the psychologic intimidation
factor yeah that's a real beautiful
thing too you know there's there's a lot
of elements to have in those dogs
there's just you know it's amazing you
see it especially in law
forcement you know but you'll have guys
that will literally stand there with six
armed officers and fight all six of them
when you know drawn-on getting tased
pepper sprayed you throw the 65 pound
point here little little mound y out in
the dudes lays straight down and yeah
it's amazing
but you know you think about it from
from again from the human component of
it's not natural to be attacked by an
animal you know nor is it something that
most people a are comfortable with B
have ever experienced most people have
mixed it up especially if they're
getting drawn on by six officers prides
probably not their first fistfight you
know but so yeah I mean that that
element of is is pretty this pretty
awesome back to the book the lacks
permissive attitude that exists in our
schools our homes in our society in
general has trickled down into how we
interact with our pets while there are
some benefits to our living in a kinder
and gentler society they're also some
huge drawbacks
this is particularly this is
particularly true as it pertains to dogs
some people believe that it's impossible
to have a well-trained dog and to never
have to physically correct that dog I
wish that were true but it's not the
case let me be clear I don't employ I
don't advocate the use of any kind of
unnecessary force but please understand
this important point if all you ever do
is reward your dog for good behavior you
love and and you have no consequences
for bad behavior then your dog will not
have a complete understanding of what's
expected so when you were talking about
you know the the fact that you sometimes
do have to use a call a pinch collar you
have to use a choke collar you might
have to use a digit was it remote collar
you might have to do that stuff in fact
you probably will yeah I mean there's
there's always the chance I mean the
best way I can kind of break it down is
think of it from raising kids or again
employees like if if the if the
consequence is is the absence of reward
that's you know you yes you may come
across a dog but again this is an
outlier exception anomaly whatever coin
phrase you want to use those aren't
realistic aspirations to have with a dog
like just like with kids like yeah hey
if you don't clean your room you're not
gonna get those peanut M&Ms
okay well I'll go do it then maybe like
you know what I'd rather not have peanut
M&Ms and just not clean my room now are
you gonna do about it you know like
you're gonna run into that as a dad
shock collar yeah two of them cattle
prod you know so the you know that it's
a bit of an oversimplification in terms
of you know what it really boils down to
is is you know when how how often you
know things like that I mean it really
is not so much a matter of if it's when
it's just being smart about how you're
implementing it so that a it's effective
I mean kind of my rules of thumb for
implementing compulsion or positive
punishment is is that it's not when
you're emotional about it
it's not when the dog does not
understand why it's happening and then
the last thing is that the instant that
the behavior has ceased the punishment
has to also what you find a lot of times
most times and especially early on if
that relationship hasn't been built and
that foundation isn't there again I
can't explain anything to a dog well a
lot of people you know we all have our
expectations I know I want the dog to
sit I don't want them to grab sandwiches
I don't watch the kids over I want him
to bark when it's 3:00 in the morning
unless there's somebody breaking in he
doesn't know any of that you know so we
have to teach them and if you again just
like with the human component if you're
trying to teach somebody something and
they don't understand what's expected of
them and you're punishing them for not
understanding it that sucks you know and
that's unfortunately that's how most
dogs go about their lives is that you
know I don't have a relationship with
this dog let me throw a prong collar an
e-collar on him and make him do these
things and then he just shuts down he's
aversive to its talk about that drill we
put the e collar on people yeah and you
have them do a little task yeah it's a
real simple you know it dovetails on to
this you know this kind of principle is
that you know again so that so you can
put yourself in a dog's shoes is that
and so what I do when I run handler
courses you know let's say it's you two
I'm gonna have you know you be the
handler echo is the dog so we're gonna
put the e collar on his bicep I'll take
you out into the next room Roger that so
I'm gonna I'm gonna take you out there
and say okay we're gonna come back in
here and I want you to get echo to take
this shell on front thing
put this here and put that there
that's his his task so for those eternal
listening it's like a menial task it's
put a pencil and a paper clip on to a
box and they're gonna be sitting on the
table in the middle of the room all
separate from each other and there's a
bunch of other stuff crap here so when
we come back in now you don't say
anything to him we're not allowed to
talk
and so now echo just starts grabbing
stuff and every time he grabs the
Sharpie he gets shocked he grabs the the
the T he gets shocked he grabs the knife
he gets shocked he messes with the paper
he gets shocked after five or six maybe
ten you know he's a strong guy who can
take take some punishment he cranked it
up he's not getting that he's messing
with the wrong stuff I'm gonna hammer
him harder what's he gonna do
very quickly he's gonna do this he's
just gonna sit here and say I'm not
touching anything anymore he becomes
aversive to all the stimulus stimuli on
on the desk on the transverse and so
what that teaches you is that if your
dog doesn't understand that that that's
what happens and that's the position
you're putting your dog in is the very
one you're in and it sucks so don't do
it is that you've got to explain to him
what you want and you do that through
shaping and reinforcing and so the
transverse is now we go out we pick a
different drill and we come back in and
now you have a clicker with humans you
can say hey the click means that it's
good with dogs obviously you have to
pair something to it but you correct in
a tree yeah you could click and give
them a jelly bean or whatever but so now
you come in and the the only absence of
that is when he met like if he grabs the
sharpie now and that's not part of the
drill nothing happens very quickly the
dog will do what's what's called learns
through self discovery and I start to
offer behaviors you probably see it in
in your dog sometimes when they just
start doing stuff looking at you if you
have something and they start doing
arbitrary movements they're trying to
figure out what it's going to take for
them to do to get what what they want
that you have and so now you wait and
once that once he grabs what you want
you mark it and so now he's like okay
well it's something with this and now
it's fun it's a game and he's trying to
figure out as mine's working as positive
everybody's having fun
the first example it sucks you know it's
painful it's stressful
there's cortisol it's chaotic and again
that dog is a plus B equals a and you
say the percentage of success is your
first method is zero production I have
not ever
done that and I've done it god knows how
many times I have never done that
experiment where somebody successfully
perform that task not one time on the
transverse I'd say the only time where
they haven't been successful is due to
brevity is that it's taking longer but
they either get really close or they
finish it and everybody's laughing you
know because then you know the whole
rest of class is watching and do they're
usually laughing during the the e-collar
one you know but but it it paints a very
clear picture because a lot of times
people they have not put their self in
the dog's shoes again just like with
leadership is you got to relate you got
to understand how it's gonna impact
people when you're implementing
different protocols or procedures or
leadership principles what does that
look like on the other side you know
doesn't matter if it makes sense to me
it doesn't matter if it if it seems
sound to me if they view it as like this
is crap it's unfair it's whatever it may
be but you've got it you've got to
figure out how to manipulate it so that
that they understand a what the
expectations are be what the
consequences are and then see ultimately
what what comes from both of those
depending on what they choose to do and
that's to me that's the beauty of
operant conditioning with with dog
training is that you're you're letting
the dog dictate the consequence and no
different than with any of us it they
enjoy it you know and it stimulates
their mind which they need which is
another benefit to bonding in
relationship with them is because if you
are the ones stimulating their mind
guess what now they want to hang out
with you more they will listen to you
more your blue chip bank and just gets
overloaded because they've had so many
positive experiences where they've had
different things that it's a desirable
on urine that doesn't mean anything to
them but they're just trying things out
and now they do it and it gets marked
and rewarded and it's fun it's a game
and it's just it's a it's a
self-replicating process that that has a
ton of benefits for you for you and the
dog I thought this part was interesting
you're just and it's important to know
as well to understand dogs a little bit
better a dogs sense of smell is
somewhere between 10,000 and 100,000
thousand times as sensitive as our own
there's a PBS television show Nova where
as guy named James Walker and this is a
quote from the book he said if you make
the analogy division what you and I can
see at a third of a mile a dog could see
more than
3,000 miles away and there's another
example
Alexandra Horowitz the author of inside
a dog did something similar but kept the
comparison in the olfactory realm you
can tell when your coffee has tea or
sugar in it by taking a sip of it a dog
could sense that same teaspoon of sugar
diluted in a million gallons of water
just by using his nose
that's insane yeah long and from a so
there's two reasons why that's important
on the working dog side it's pretty it's
pretty clear to see the benefits that
that that has in terms of you know
sniffing explosives that are buried and
detecting people that are hidden in
false floors and tracking people and
things of that nature on the on the pet
dog side where that comes into play is
that is that same you know from a
relationship standpoint is that they
recognize you by the way you smell they
recognize your kids by the way they
smell in terms of training interacting
with them using treats rewards toys
things of that nature it you know it
plays big big dividends or pays big
dividends too so it's just one more
component that you know the reason that
the book is called the Navy SEAL way and
I if there's one thing I could say that
I wish I had done a better job with was
kind of relying why why that is is that
you know when I think about our
reputation and our efficacy and success
as a community since its inception why
is that you know and it's it's
everything that's in this book just
related to dogs it's well it comes by
selection you know have a have a very
stringent selection process but then
above and beyond that you know seals
don't have this the success and
reputation because because they're good
shots or in good shape or have great
intelligence or have some of the best
platforms and augments in terms of close
air support is our whatever it's because
they have all of those things you know
it's it's managing the every single
intangible that you can possibly
manipulate and control and stack that
deck in your favor so it's not just
training it's not just selecting the
right dog it's not just feeding them
good food it's not just keeping them in
good
physical condition and an ideal body
weight it's not anyone you know
component of that it's all of them and
so that the Navy SEAL way it's it's more
about us on a big scale in terms of how
how we've gotten to where we've gotten
and by using all of those same same
concepts you know and I used all of
those same concepts as a trainer in
terms of my selection process is is
god-awful you know there's times where
we would go on on trips to go find dogs
and and and since then even were you
know I may look at dozens or even
hundreds of them to find one you know
you know Sims I would say probably
attrition rates are even even worse than
than buds you know and you may have a
fraction of a percentage or in the
single-digit percentage of dogs that I
look at that actually end up making it
so you know but it's it's that crux of
and again same same with business it's
like it's not just having good
accounting it's not just having good
leadership it's not good just having
good recruiting it's not just having
good budgeting and funding it's it's all
of those things and when you manipulate
the environment and stack the deck in
your favor make things very consistent
in black and white have an ideal have an
idea in your mind of what that finished
product is and be able to visualize that
know where you're at develop a plan and
execute it again it just goes back to
the the microcosm that dog training is
that that mimics life but talk about
this thing in the in the book you talk
about look for the intelligence behind a
mistake what do you mean by that so I
found that pretty cool yeah so the you
know the intelligence behind the mistake
is is essentially a teaching moment you
know is that understand why it was made
ultimately it's it's you as the handlers
fault for why mistakes are made but but
understand why the dog made the mistake
you know and and it could be you know
it's generally gonna gonna be reduced
down to lack of communication on your
part a a confusion of expectations on
the dogs the same with humans same with
humans those same with humans yeah and
then and then the last thing which is
probably one of the most imperative
things saying with humans is is bringing
emotion into the equation dogs are while
they have some
simple emotions that mimic humans
they're nowhere near as complex one of
the jokes I start a lot of my speeches
out with is we're gonna find out who
loves you more your spouse or your dog
locked both of them in the trunk of your
car for two hours after two hours can
pop the trunk who's happier to see you
you know dog doc hey buddy where you
been you know your life's gonna slap the
hell out of you so but that they are
that simple you know and it's it's an
Achilles heel of sorts we were talking
about it before we came on came on air
is the iPhone you know that that's
really dogs are actually so simple that
we as humans because we're so much more
complicated now we think and emotionally
charged and what have you that we make
them way more complicated and harder to
Train than they actually are
it's a we need to oversimplify it and
end to me not to get too far off on a
tangent but that's it's kind of like
world world policy you know foreign
policy from from an international
standpoint is it sometimes the simplest
solutions are the best for the most
complex problems you know foreign policy
being a bar fight you know if if you're
gonna go walk into that bar you're gonna
get in a fight you know and you better
bring everything to bear to make sure
that you're safe but realize that by
walking in there no matter whose side
you take no matter what happens you're
gonna create at least one enemy probably
several you know so you better make damn
sure that going into that bar is worth
going into before you go into it to me
that's a pretty simple solution it's a
simple way to look at the world's
problems we don't do that you know we
over complicate it but it's that same
same mentality with a dog though is is
that you know most times it's the most
simple solution to what you think or
perceive is the most complex problem and
it's really not that complicated yeah
yeah you talk about you go through a
whole section that's about reading your
dog and and what signals to look for and
it's the same thing with people you
don't get to learn how to read people
but you talk about their eyes you talk
about their ears what their ears are
doing you're talking about what their
tail and this is these are all things
you told me when I was getting my dog is
you know things to look for and man they
were spot-on just just looking at their
posture interestingly we just had Jordan
Peterson on we talked a lot about
posture he's got a new book out called
12 12 rules for life in the first
chapter this is how to live your life
the first chapter
stand up straight with your shoulders
back it's like yeah and you can see that
in dogs and you can see that you know in
the way that you stand around your dog
you've already talked about that a bunch
today but just to make sure that you
have good posture as like simple as that
might sound and what do you look for in
a posture of a dog so this is where it
depends on what the what you're looking
for what the end goal is if I'm looking
for a pet then I probably don't want a
cocky scorpion tail ears up chest out
looking like King Kong and like he owns
the place for a good strong working dog
yeah I want a dog that's gonna make make
my back-end pucker by grabbing a leash
and opening his gate and clipping it to
like his dogs making me a little nervous
because he's walking around looking at
me like I don't sweat you that's one of
the biggest misconceptions is growling
you know people think you know growling
growling is weakness
growling is is being scared and and it's
peacock feathers essentially it's it's a
dogs way of saying you're making me
uncomfortable I'm gonna do this and in
hopes that it makes you you know it
calls your bluff and backs you down when
I see a dog growls I know I can get in
his head faster than a dog that's
standing there looking at me with his
tail just feather in a little bit with
his eyes pinpoint and dot you know non
non dilated pupils and looking at me
like dude bring it and you know that's
the dog I worry about not the dog Rylan
with his with his hair up and his ears
back and his and his lips curled you
know that dog I know I can run him if
need be but it's just a matter of
grabbing ahold of yourself and saying
let's we're gonna do the man dance and
I'm coming after you and 99 times out of
a hundred that dog doesn't want anything
to do with it but you know for a pet you
know again it depends on you know am i
active do I want a dog it's gonna play a
deterrent role in terms of protection
and you know do I just want an active
companion do I want a docile dog that
you know my kids can snuggle with you
know so to me again just like with the
kind of the the macrocosm of you know
what what do you want out of the dog you
know let that drive your decision and
work backwards from there but no but I
think the key point is here know that
there's traits or visual clues that you
can look for that indicate what kind of
a dog what kind of personality the dog
has you know so then and if you don't
know those and you just
go to a random place and you pick the
dog that came up to you fastest and was
wiggling or the dog that was all shy and
looks so cute in the corner there's
consequences to get in those dogs and
they're all over the place and if you
don't know what you're getting you're
wrong
yeah well and you know the conversation
that we had before you selected yours
you know that you hear a lot of things
because I'll turn the dog up upside down
or put him on his back and see if he's
calm you know and there's people that
know if he's calling us the one you want
if he's acted that's the one you know to
me it's all talk crap honestly what I
like to do is is just like in any other
selection process I want to take the dog
out of his comfort zone and see now see
how he how he reacts his comfort zone is
where he's been raised where he's been
living with his littermates with his mom
you know if you go to a breeders house
and you evaluate a puppy with the the
litter running around and the mom
standing there you are not getting an
accurate representation of what that
dog's genetic components are not even
close there there are so many things
that have been smoked and mirrored in
the dogs benefit he's gonna look much
stronger and better and active and drive
here and dominant and whatever then then
he truly is if you want to really see
that dog at his genetic face-value take
him somewhere where you know he hasn't
been by himself you told me Home Depot
yeah I think is it great because there's
things going on at home because stuff
there's noises there's a bunch of people
running around there's other dogs in
there there's kids there's all kinds of
chaos going on in the help oh yeah I
mean you'll find out about a dog's
environmental nerve faster than anything
there you know and so but it can be
anywhere busy it could be a parking lot
it could be Walmart it could be an
airport I mean wherever you can find
that home depot is gonna get flooded
with us dogs by the way just FYI test
dogs like the little puppies they're not
potty trained yet yes
so fYI for everyone here here's a cool
story you put in here back to the book
Carlos came to my care several years ago
he was 7 years old at the time but he
had bit had to retire from the teams
during an operation in Iraq on a raid
that resulted in an intense firefight he
and his handler approached a building
suspected of housing cached munitions
just short of the entryway a remotely
detonated ie D threw the pair back
several yards Carlos broke his back and
his high
legs and hips and collapsed his sinuses
and his lungs for privacy reasons I
can't go to the injuries his handler
sustained other than to say that they
were extensive medical personnel acted
quickly and both the dog and the handler
survived
Carlos nearly prevented that emergency
treatment from being initiated despite
the severity of his injuries he crawled
to his handlers side and took up a
defensive perimeter near his fallen
comrade no one trained Carlos to do that
he did it for one reason
loyalty and not you know that can't be
taught you know just like it can't be in
people it can be reinforced you know it
can be conditioned tweaked a little bit
one way or another it can be broken for
sure but that that is a in my opinion
eight a primal genetically inherited
trait that either exists or doesn't just
like with heart you know and that's
that's something that's excruciatingly
ly rare obviously both in humans and and
dogs and it's one of the one of the ways
I test a dog is that as I want to test
their heart and and see if if when push
comes to shove if they if they want to
fight me you know and Carlos was was a
warrior of the highest magnitude no
doubt about it
you know you know he spent several years
with us and then ended up I retired him
to a dog friend of mine in Florida that
had him for a little while and the last
picture I got him got of him was
watching the Super Bowl laying on a
leather couch with a Kong in his mouth I
got a couple weeks before he died right
oh yeah he got got the full spectrum got
the full retirement yeah good deal you
know dogs possessed here back to the
book dogs possess the capability to be
loyal capability to be loyal a dog owner
as a dog owner you should not take that
loyalty for granted or exploit it you
should work to give your dog a reason to
be the most loyal to you he can possibly
be I mean does that not go 100 percent
with human beings as well it's it's you
know let your dog know that he can trust
you yeah be a leader make sure people
know that they can trust you I mean come
on here's an another interesting little
story you got in here so you got a guy
Bob who whenever he's working on his car
he loses temper goes crazy throws tools
around he doesn't know why his dog
doesn't you know like it
back to the book when Bob lost his cool
even though Bob didn't direct any of his
anger at his dog Rudy the dog wanted no
part of that scenario maybe we was more
sensitive to those kind of responses
than other dogs might have been but Rudy
basically lost respect for Bob bob was
the guy he expected to be in command and
in control and he wasn't what made
things worse for Bob was that he knew
that was the case so so the reason I
pulled that one out is because again I
talk about all time hey if you lose you
if you lose your temper as a leader
you're weak you're you're gonna look
weak your gonna appear to be weak and
and some people can't control their
temper and that's just wrong but even a
dog even a dog will look at a leader
that loses his temper and go okay I
can't like in you I'm not following you
that's me I would say not not so much
even a dog I would say a specialist well
there you go you know because it's you
know I can't I can't talk to my dog and
say hey sorry about that I lost my cool
it's not gonna happen again you know I'm
still your boss but you know let's let
me make it up to you you know whatever
not that that's how you'd approach it
anyway but but my point is is that you
know you you have that that a plus B
equals C principle in everything you
know it's whether it's shaping behavior
that you desire it's eliminating
undesirable problem behaviors that
you've inadvertently created it's you
know breaking breaking trust and ruining
relationships you know one of the things
that I like to tell people and again
it's with with you know human
relationships also is that trust is like
a piece of paper and when when you break
it it's crumpling it up into a ball you
know you you can flatten it back out you
can iron it you can get it real close
but it will never be the same you know
if you truly break it you know the way
that a lot of people do be careful with
that you know because it you only get
one one crack at ruining it and then and
then you're faced with an uphill battle
the nice thing with dogs where they're
more forgiving and and pliable mentally
than than our humans you put them in the
trunk of the car for a couple hours and
you're still alright yeah then you did
the transverse of that is if you show
your dog that your own flap when you
consistently project an image of
authority that your dog will understand
you can count on you so don't lose your
temper
don't do that as a leader either here's
another one that you throw in rewards
like Corrections should be proportional
the surest way to reduce the
effectiveness of a reward is to overuse
it and that's obviously true with people
as well first of all if you're if you're
not just with your punishment and
somebody makes a small mistake and you
can hammer them destructively that's not
helping you and at the same time if
everything that they do good you're
jumping up and down like a cheerleader
that's not going to do you any good
either it's same with a dog sure and you
know the other thing that the varying
the reward schedule and also there's
times that goes all into variable
rewards yeah right isn't there some kind
of well there's a psychological help
with dogs it's an excuse you told me
about something with with iPhones though
yeah yeah like you're looking for the
little thing to pop up and you think
maybe this is the message from from
whoever the president yeah this could be
the one who don't want instead it's just
an advertisement for something yeah
sometimes but one day it is a message
from the president but that keeps you in
the game how many of those so you use
variable rewards with the dogs so with
with training it's kind of again it just
falls into a cumulative process at first
it's every time you know so that there's
the consistency so that that's the
explanation of the expectation is that
you do this you get that you do this you
get that until now it's Spitz wired once
it's wired now it becomes just like if
every time you pick anything pick
anything you like you know for every
Friday we're having steak and ice cream
like after a while it's like no steak
and ice cream again see that that dog
will get to a point where now it's
actually we're not having steak and ice
cream we're having tofu burgers joke's
on you he's like wait what you know so
now whatever it took that week to get
steak an ice cream on Friday maybe I'm
gonna work a little harder and you'll
see that out of them and so and this is
more on the on the competitive side but
you know when you're judged on on
flashiness and precision and speed of
execution when it comes to different
behavioral components of obedience
routines and people want to speed those
up and make them more laser-like in
their precision that's a very effective
way to do it is it now sometimes you
get it sometimes you don't so now the
dog is it's the lottery mentality of
doing scratch offs you know I mean
nobody wins the Powerball but the
scratch-offs it's like wow you know made
12 bucks yeah you know I can almost buy
what I just spent on them you know I
almost got my money back on buy them
again but but we're you know human
beings are wired that same way how many
people waste their money on scratch-offs
a bunch of them for that same reason
it's a it's a psychological aspect that
that actually is very powerful in a dog
but the caveat to that is that you know
make sure that it's it's an ingrained
conditioned response before you start
doing that but yet it is powerful in
terms of the flooding when I when I'm
bridging certain things together like if
I want to go from you know I'll teach a
dog to recall which has come to me first
when I'm teaching him to get his
back-end into you know his shoulder hits
my knees starting it get kind of a
healing position in the sitting position
that's one component and then actually
walking off and then starting to heal
when I want to bridge all that together
sit so you know if I just give him the
the what I call plots command which is
Dutch for place is it the dog you know
it does all of that you know he comes
here he gets into the plots and then we
and then we heal off basically when I
bridge certain things together if I've
been building a couple different
components and when it clicks the very
first time I'll flood five six seven
rewards all all right at that at once so
that he's like Oh payday it's a jackpot
yeah so it's it's kind of almost a
successive approximation in terms of you
know teaching different different steps
no different than in jujitsu and
different elements of a move or whatever
and then once it's paired all together
now they get the tap out they're like
sweet you know same same guys everything
yes ding ding ding ding ding ding
back to the book beware that your dog
has no concept of what words mean in
other words if you repeatedly say the
word down as in down down down your dog
will associate that more lengthy
expression as his cue to lie down keep
it simple and clear simple clear concise
language I did that you talk about in
the book I did the broccoli thing with
my with my dog with my wife and she was
all shocked you know because it I was
like hey your dog you know even though
you think your dog
knows what you're saying he actually has
no idea and then you talk about in the
book I did with my dog yesterday I said
hey our dog has no idea what he's what
we're saying which is what do you mean I
said he doesn't know what's it means she
said what do you mean I said watch this
and so I gave him the calm he came over
and I said broccoli and he sat right
down just like I said sit and she was
all looking all confused and I said yeah
that's right these dogs don't know what
is it but it's the body language and
it's the expectations and whatever
little subtle cues I have when I want
him to sit I did it and I just the word
came out of my mouth was broccoli
context I don't present what dogs are
you know the beauty of dogs is how
powerful context the Achilles heel is
also context in it for that same reason
but yeah it's a it's important to make
that distinction that's where you know
using using that shaping of the behavior
as your best friend in terms of you know
like I said I use a classroom you know
there's a reason why libraries and
classrooms are the environments that
they are so when we teach our kids what
we want them to know it's a
distraction-free environment it's you
know positive learning experience it's a
it's a petri dish for education when
when you try to do things where you know
the dog is in the house and doing all
these other things you know there's all
these other stimuli going on and it's
distracting and the dogs not picking it
up and it's not building that context so
I use a 40 by 40 training classroom it's
just it's a fenced-in area with nothing
in it and we go in there and I just
stand there and wait for them to start
doing stuff and then I mark it and
reward it and shape it and then from
there I start to shape a little micro
nuanced you know the dog just turns his
head won't you know a fraction of a
degree one one direction I mark that and
reward if I'm trying to teach a place
command he looks at the bed I market and
reward he takes one step a mark and
reward and I just build on that over and
over and over and the neat thing is once
they dogs kind of have to learn how to
learn that way you'll see that light
bulb go on as soon as they understand
okay you have what I want and I have to
earn it I have to figure out what it's
going to take to get it and they start
to offer these offer behaviors through
self discovery then that is when when
you own their mind and you can teach
them anything
and it's one of the first things I
teaches is a place command for that that
simple reason alone is that it's so
powerful on a dog if he can look at me
and he knows
dude has what I want and I have to
actually go away from it to get it then
then it's its own step and I know this
question is gonna get asked all the time
but you put it in here not only is it
possible to teach your dogs to perform
tricks but I believe you should
regardless of the dog's age so you can
in fact teach an old dog new tricks
everybody's question yeah do you do you
fill up the hard drive at some point
where they can't learn anything new
without forgetting something else not
any more than any of us you know they
can learn they can they can we'll
continue to learn and to me one of the
reasons dogs as with people expire
earlier than they probably need to is
because a lack of that stimulation that
mental stimulation you know even if the
mind or even if the body can't can't
perform there's a lot of other ways that
you can get dogs to stimulate their mind
and keep them younger and healthier and
happier than then just letting them
expire on a dog bed you know five feet
away from you
letting your heart get too much in the
way of your head
and what's best for your dog will end up
causing that heart more pain in the long
run discipline equals freedom amen
right I've been if you have an
undisciplined dog that dogs gonna be
miserable you're gonna be miserable
everything sucks yeah pretty much
absolutely yeah I mean it's like I said
I mean the the that's one of my big
goals moving into this year is is
basically starting like a shelter
campaign of signing up for the online
training saving a dog and we're gonna be
launching it here real soon but you know
I I I firmly believe you know whether
you want to call it a calling or
whatever is that you know my goal is to
is to revolutionize how your average
everyday dog owner views communicates
with and interacts with their dog
because how many dogs a year gets sent
to the pound 3.3 million dogs every year
gets surrendered to shelters across this
country and it varies your a year but
usually between six and six hundred and
eighty and seven hundred and fifty
thousand dogs
a year get euthanized it's over two
thousand dogs every day getting put to
sleep in this country even at those
numbers you know and it's not as bad as
it as it was but it's still
astronomically high and the way I look
at it very simply is that you know
shelters god bless them are great great
resources and we as Americans very
charitable have opened up our hearts and
wallets and provided pretty astounding
resources for animals whether it's ASPCA
HSUS whatever shelters rescue
organizations you name it but to me it's
it's it's no different than throwing
money at the symptom you know it's not
addressing the problem you know the
problem is why are they getting there in
the first place I mean because with
eighty three million dogs out there you
can't have enough resources to
accommodate that you know and so it's
like it's like the the pharmaceutical
industry you know it's it's it's dealing
with the symptoms and not trying to fix
fix the problem you know of course there
is potentially some politics involved
with that in terms of maintaining
funding and salaries and jobs I get all
that but to me a shelter's number-one
goal should be to have zero dogs in it
you know if you're not if that's not
your goal you're wrong and I'll call any
one of them out right now you know your
goal should be to be out of a job in in
my opinion you know and to me that
starts with with teaching people how to
communicate with their dogs and it's
everything that we've talked about but
it's it's really not that complicated
you know and then the the gratification
you get from doing it yourself and the
understanding of your dog it transcends
just that you know just like you know
with what you what you do you know you
can take all of these same lessons and
apply them to your kids to your spouse
to your business partners to your
employees or whatever and it all works
the same way yeah we're gonna close out
the book here I'm gonna run through
these fundamental principles you have
and and as I'm saying them think about
not just dogs but everyone that doesn't
have a dog think about people anyone
that's in a leadership position think
about leading those people as it applies
to dogs
one look at things from the dogs
perspective how often is it we get of
someone that works for us and we don't
think about what's going through their
brain and why what we're saying how what
we're saying to them or how what we're
making them doing back some appreciate
the differences in how dogs use their
senses to perceive the world same thing
think about the people that you've got
working for you look at the intelligence
behind mistake you already already
talked about that reward good behavior
uh uh but how often do we not do that as
a leader punished or extinguish bad
behavior duh again but how often do we
let little things slide we just if
you're letting things slide if somebody
wants to be late day after day oh that's
okay we're saying it's okay next be
consistent in the application of awards
and Punishment well there you go
this is especially true with kids if
you're not consistent with the kids like
they don't learn mmm and and I think
opposite of dogs actually a kid if they
think they can get away with it once
like a variable reward but a variable
punishment if they think you thinking
about they're gonna gamble they can get
away do it again dogs little dogs will
test the water on your pretty hard that
way a lot of them are more more
intuitive and sharp than you think but
keep emotion out of the evaluation of
good and bad and the application of
punishments this is super smart
especially with kids and with employees
and with dogs but if you're punishing
the people or your workers or your
employees or your dogs out of anger
you're you're not doing a good job
you're not doing a good job in fact just
FYI when I have to do punishment with my
kids I do it in like the most
cold-blooded serial murderer kind of way
that I can the gloves instructor as if
it completely emotionless I was like
well you know unfortunately I have to do
this because of your behavior so go
ahead and report to the garage you know
so they're gonna they're gonna get
hammered but I think that's better
it's far more impactful you know I mean
think about a bugs instructor like now
I'm really screaming at you yeah you
know it's the it's the the antithesis of
the Marine Corps di like it's just white
noise at that point understand they're
like yeah
when that dudes like whispering like I'm
gonna I'm gonna snatch the life out of
your soul crush it right in front of
your face you know kid sitting there
like 18 years old blowing his anal
glands like Jesus what did I sign up for
next understand how dogs communicate
overwhelmingly through body language and
used that understanding and method of
communication back to them to elicit the
kinds of behaviors we want and we talked
about this before in the podcast you
know you probably heard this before but
they say humans humans communicate even
though we're all verbal and all that is
an 80% is nonverbal 80% is nonverbal
this is probably someone will say no
it's not 80 at 78 but it's a huge
percentage is nonverbal well to me to me
where I think you know not to get too
off track but where the disparity is and
is that in with technology so much of
our communication doesn't involve
interaction right you know it's emails
its text messages even its phone calls
whatever you know so I think in person
maybe you know but because there's such
that's so watered down right by
everything you know well people do this
I mean I've been working with businesses
all the time we I uncover all kinds of
people I have on all kinds of problems
because they're only communicating
through email or through text and
therefore the people are picking up on
all those other signals so we have
relationships that get destroyed because
you know I made a joke to you about
something and it was in a text message
and and I didn't put a lol yeah emoji
after it so you didn't think I was
joking all of a sudden we got an issue
like so so this is definitely something
that we have to remember that's why I
have like a rule in emails
I don't joke around and emails yeah like
I don't know make jokes and emails
unless I just completely if we know each
other and we we can get we get there but
I'm not joking around you know if I have
a client I'm not saying you know I'll be
there in a few weeks and hopefully I'll
be able to sort your ass out there
they're like wait wait a second even
though I'd be kidding yeah but they
don't know that through the email back
to the book determined our needs and
understand how a dog's prey Drive energy
level and other physical traits
contribute to a matrix of behavior what
does that say
your people know your people what's
driving them what are they motivated by
what's gonna make them work harder next
provide a dog with ample amounts of
exercise and interaction with other dogs
and people in a multitude of different
environments what I liked about that is
yeah the the obviously exercise
interaction multiple of different
environments is where I see people that
are in a training capacity they train
people only in one environment and so
they get outside that environment they
fall apart no feed him a diet with
maximum of health benefits within our
means Hey right eat good food steak yeah
basically we know we all know her
furniture I brought home some of my Bros
gave me a a cow femur the other day I
brought it home for my dog just a raw
cow femur you want to talk about a
pumped-up dog rock and roll yeah he's
still just getting after that fit that's
what nature intended yeah before
undergoing formal training develop a
bond of mutual trust and respect so get
that relationship going before you
demand a bunch of stuff from people
become the authority figure in a dog's
life that he wants and needs take the
time to be patient do multiple
repetitions building different levels of
distraction employee variable reward
schedules all to ensure that a concept
is firmly embedded in dog's mind now
we'll talk a little bit about jiu-jitsu
here you got to do the repetition and
then you've got to do it in different
you know you you gotta you got an arm
lock you got a try an arm lock live
rolling a hundred times before you get
one and at least 100 maybe more and in
order to shorten that time you got to do
more drills and then you can shorten
that time from 100 maybe you know they
got to do it forty four times before it
works you think about when you can learn
a new move in jujitsu
it can take a long time the better you
understand it in the isolated training
environment the quicker you can be able
to do it live
yeah but and from a behavioral
standpoint it's the same thing like
teach it in that sterile classroom and
then move it into the living environment
and going out for walks going past dog
parks you know busy yeah playgrounds
whatever is it you know people like yeah
he's doing great in the classroom and I
take him to the park and he just loses
his mind like where did you bridge that
yeah yeah you can't go from third grade
to you know the sophomore in college and
that's what you're doing like you're not
you missed you missed about 15 steps in
between there you know so my dog was
distracted in Walmart you know locating
idiot next use good problem-solving
skills to identify the root cause of a
problem and work out the solution to
resolve the issue and not just hide it I
get another thing you see this in
relationships and companies where they
just everyone is hiding this problem no
one will address the problem no one's
going to address the problem so if you
got problems default aggressive get
aggressive find a solution to problem
and implement it that kind of wraps up
this book like I said team dog is the
name of the book how to train your dog
the Navy SEAL way and good stuff in
there not just for dogs but for humans
as well and Mike obviously appreciate
your service and not only what you did
when you're in the teams but everything
you've done and did once you got out of
the teams and thanks for coming on the
podcast now I know you got a bunch of
things going on right now yeah well
first off I appreciate you having me on
it's a it's an honor and happy to happy
to do it yeah in terms of everything I
have going on I mean the to me the crux
of what I would pass on to to anybody
listening is is again is is the is
really trying to get to the the root
core of of communicating with your dog
and and you know to me if if nothing
else let it be an experiment and
practice for the rest of your
relationships you know because it does
transpire or transcend rather you know
just just training a dog but the online
training just a month-by-month the other
thing and go to team dog pet to check
that out it's team dog docked at dump
that's where you have online training
where people can learn
to solve these problems that they have
with a dog to build a good relationship
with a dog entering their dog yeah it's
just it's a monthly lesson it's a
cumulative process it starts out just
like everything we talked about building
a relationship for shaping a reinforcing
behavior and then working on
extinguishing things correcting problems
etc we're in the halfway through the
second year of it it's gone gotten some
really good feedback there's forums that
has I get on there and I answer
questions every Monday with with all the
the members and people interact with
each other and give each other advice
and post videos and a bunch of other
stuff we're going to launch some
affiliate partnership programs here with
with people getting other people to sign
up soon but that in conjunction with the
book and then launching treecko's
training franchises which are gonna
augment all of the people out there that
are subscribers so basically you know
it's working with certified Draco's and
team dog trainers all over the country
that have these franchises everywhere
that help you go through this monthly
training curriculum and you know that
the crux of it though is you know just
like with anything you need help from
some people you need guidance with
learning olympic lifts or jujitsu moves
or whatever but you mean you have to put
the time in yourself but this will allow
people to you know to to seek some some
guidance in person from people if
they're having specific issues or
whatever that they're not able to get
from the online stuff but we've had just
overwhelming feed positive feedback on
success story after success story you
know these 65 year old grandmother's
that have their Labradoodle out there
you know healing and walking around dog
parks and stuff and then they're just
loving it's pretty awesome but so that's
that's kind of the big big thing that
you talked about tri coast I don't even
know if we talked about tri coast yeah
tri goes is the company that you formed
up while you were still in know so this
actually my second dog company but I
formed it a little over five years ago
and it's the the crux of it is is
personal protection dogs police dogs
military dogs we do sell up a fair
number of dogs to private individuals
for you know the personal protection
aspect and that's kind of what I was
born and bred out of in conjunction with
putting on a lot of police seminars and
selling police dogs and teaching at
conferences and stuff like that but
but yeah so that's that's my for-profit
company if you in terms of everything
that I have going on the best place to
go is just micro uncom that that is the
resource that talks about the team dog
online stuff that Raikou stuff the
speaking engagements the book for that
or you know the franchise stuff coming
up or even the warrior dog foundation
the books that I've written it's kind of
a landing page of everything that I have
going on Mike Ritland comm and the
warrior dog foundation again you
mentioned a couple times but just give a
little bit of a plug for that through
people know what it is so we're a dog
foundation we started it back in August
of 2010 and we've taken in a little over
80 dogs at this point started off with
just doing special operations dogs biet
seal dogs Rangers whatever and we've
taken in a lot of police dogs contract
working dogs military working dogs and
kind of our main main goal and function
with that is to act as a as an
indefinite sanctuary for those dogs
first and foremost when we get them in
we evaluate them some of them we've been
able to repurpose rehabilitate and get
to police departments and say you know
some of them have come in spent a few
months and then we've gotten them back
to back to service with working with
them and kind of unwinding their mind a
little bit using a lot of the same
principles that we've been talking about
today but more than anything is that you
know these dogs are at that kind of were
their last resort you know they were
going to get the blue juice here within
days and and we step in and take them
and either just you know continually try
to rehabilitate them to where we can
either rehome them to a civilian
application or another Police Department
or whatever or we just let them live out
their life be a dog have fun chase balls
and and run around the woods and hang
out and retire and out to pasture so to
speak but Warrior Dog Foundation org is
the website for that if you want to
check it out and of course we're always
gracious and appreciative of any support
or if there's someone that listens to
this podcast and gets all fired up to
get a dog obviously get the book I'm
gonna tell you that right now get the
books so you can make a good assessment
make a good judgment and think it's a
lot of work to have a dog I have four
kids I've had dogs multiple dogs when I
had
a bunch of kids we actually didn't have
dogs for a while because kids and dogs
are a lot of work if you're not willing
to put the work into the dog then that's
you're not gonna be a good parent is
that the right no you're actually a good
dog owner so yeah I almost went sideways
there so yeah gonna be a bad dog daddy
your daddy yeah you're not gonna be a
good dog owner and believe me I had a
fight I got three daughters and one son
and for the years of me beating them
down saying no dog no dog no dog because
I knew that I couldn't put enough time
and effort into it to make it a dog have
a good life and the dog be squared away
and be disciplined and be able to you
know protect my family
so it took a while to get there but then
finally when my kids were old enough you
know I got one out of the house and now
we have a good environment for it
and so think about that before you run
out and buy a dog yeah no absolutely I
mean it's it's like with anything you
know don't don't do impulse decisions do
your due diligence and research and just
like you wouldn't just now let's adopt
the kid and see what happens you know I
don't don't do the same thing with a dog
yeah I'm bored it's Friday night let's
go to the let's go to the shelter and
pick up a new dog yeah you're not a good
call all right
echo we learned a lot about how to help
dogs and train dogs maybe you could tell
us how we can help ourselves a little
bit is it true that no dogs don't have a
personality they have a dog malady get
it I need to work on the operant
conditioning with that Ghost yeah anyway
good news is chocolate supplements
finally when I say finally not like yes
finally like because the whole world is
waiting yeah yeah like four decades kind
can I jump in one quick second before
that of course we are launching a tri
Coast Dog supplement line in the next
couple of weeks
oh speaking of supplements go on try
Coast down there for dogs I'm not
stepping on your toes but yeah so you
know check check check in yeah
stepping on my toes at all expect in
fact I expect a package of miles you
would like okay ma'am just got a butt
and he's got your advertisement in there
hey pay for that what kind of
supplements though like what is it
supplement just made yes starting out
it's going to be different oils and then
we'll get into college and later this
year and stuff like that it's all
cognitive driven you know CBD and and
different essential oil stuff and joint
supplements and and stuff like that so
it's a kind of a kind of a mix of a few
different things but most of it is is
for joint pain for overall health
cognitive function things like that yeah
and it all stems from the warrior dog
research that we've done in terms of
what works with them in terms of raw
foods and different joint supplements
and again the collagen is a big thing
and just kind of drawing off of all of
our experience with that but keep
physically maintained yeah anything
that's a big component you know it's
like a bunch of broken warriors you know
they take take a lot extra a lot extra
care and an animal husbandry to keep
them keep them sound yeah echo is using
that as a segue I could feel it feel it
well same thing yeah cuz Jocko
supplements chuckles super krill oil for
joints and joint warfare obviously also
for joints glucosamine chondroitin
curcumin somebody just asked me about do
you know what you Jitsu don't your
fingers hurt because you're with the
ghee oh right yeah yeah yeah it's it's
the common answer is yeah of course they
hurt the joint warfare answer and the
krill oil answer is no it's not too bad
yeah
your hands will get like sore like
muscle sword yeah but my finger and then
again it depends on how much of the key
and how much grabbing you do have I do
have a low key grabbing game yes awkward
thing it's not that I don't grab the key
cuz I certainly do okay but if yo I grab
that key but if you are determined you
get that look on your face like you want
me to let go your key guess what I'm
gonna do I'm gonna hold on it for the
last millisecond and when you pull with
all your might I'm gonna let go of it
because I'm doing something else but
yeah there's you you see the Miao
brothers yeah you seen their hands
yeah they're all jacked up and you've
watched their Jiu Jitsu game that's
because they're just they will not let
go that guy though get into beard
positions and it's it's gonna hurt I
don't even know if joint warfare would
help him out probably at least a little
bit but maybe a little no that's that's
your you know that's the life you chose
kind of thing with the Carnegie yeah and
yeah you have a real low grabbing yeah
like I grab medium regular geek grabbing
yeah um no joint pain by the way yeah
I'm on krill oil krill oil water I think
it's gonna help regardless I was that
curious yeah ya know there are certain
people if you have a like like surgeons
we don't know people that are surgeons
that trained jiu-jitsu yeah you got you
cannot have a high the commitment Gregor
grabbing commitment that's really what
I'm talking I finally figured it out
that's what I I grab the key a lot but
my commitment on the guy grabs is
relatively low compared to somebody
that's all about all about that like
that's 100% committed to geographic yeah
that's true to me it's just a setup
though like I when you're great when
you're decide you're gonna get back
you're gonna break my grip I'm there's
since that's my game yeah you go to
break my get rip I know that you're
going to break my grip and I have the
only the chain of events are about oh
yeah yeah it's kind of like when your
kid when you when you're playing with
your friend or whatever like pulling his
arm try to pull it back you're pulling
more and more and then like you let go
and you trip his leg he falls back same
thing with chocos geek grabbing to set
up yeah yeah set up nonetheless if your
fingers are sore from your key grabbing
commitment levels super krill joint
warfare mine was the elbows am i back
good good to go now also the
subscription is now available oh yeah
from what I understand well what's cool
is because we have the data right
everyone talks about the data we have
the big data on on super grill on joint
warfare and what's cool is when people
buy it
mmm they buy more yeah it's is that the
best indicator I can see because when
you try it you you feel it then you want
it and so people had requested we put
subscription so if you want to subscribe
just get
krill delivered to you yeah you can do
that like a monthly yeah you can do
mostly you can do every two weeks and
you can do with that you could do with
the joint warfare you can do with the
discipline yeah is you lacking
discipline yeah yeah you can get it now
some people that's all they need just a
little discipline and boom they're good
to go
speaking of which discipline what is
discipline it's a cognitive physical
supplement yeah pre-workout from me
pre-mission free life for all it's free
mission if you have a mission
you take the discipline it'll help it
there's some cognitive stuff in there
some a little bit of caffeine right yes
it's a little bit fired about 15
milligrams yeah cuz you go beyond that
and I start to feel like how much is one
cup of coffee it's like 45 or 50 right
no I want to say a cup of coffee
oh yes you I think you are right I look
like a standard 45 or 50 yeah so you
figure 15 you know third yep something
like that's what's in white tea by the
way there's no coincidence that that's a
little bit more than I thought not that
that's a lot it's not a lot at all
really fifteen or is people don't want
anybody that's a coffee drinker yeah
they won't nothing to it yeah they'd
like drinking 1/3 a cup of coffees not
that much they're gonna want more for
sure but it's not nothing
yeah something that's true yeah yeah so
that's good to me that's good
nonetheless uh you know you take it
before you do some something that
requires physical and mental stuff just
like how we're talking about there's you
Jets you don't take it before jiu-jitsu
though no I do take it I don't take it
before I wait before you work out yeah
cuz I don't it's early in the morning
not about that I don't know what you're
drinking now this is white tea I had a
drink of that the first trick I had
wished was the discipline you know
flavored it is and it actually tastes
good cuz chuckles like that yeah I needs
it to taste really delicious
it tastes good oh he's to my palate
again and over is it wait who I'm
talking about your own Mikey Mike is
yeah yeah same thing that happened on
Jordan Peterson podcast apparently I
have a sensitive palate what is it
refined refined but it's not
so yes discipline tastes good
yo JIT amélie tastes good you know what
you can do and I don't recommend this at
night well it's a little risky it tastes
good enough to have for dessert really
it's got a little sweetness to it right
it's got a little sweetness you can take
you can take it for dessert cuz you
think oh man it's more like a little oh
boom there you have some discipline you
gotta watch out cuz it's if unless you
have I try not to take it if I don't
have something to do right now and if
it's eight o'clock sometimes I eat late
at night cuz I can eat when I get done
training if I don't want to be taking it
that late at night but why cuz the
caffeine cuz the cat just the caffeine
and there's the whole whole film like
that the micro dose of caffeine so but I
have last night I did because I'm
prepping like 14 podcast right now so I
I had some discipline late last night so
I could gain what what do you mean
dessert though so would he sprinkle it
on a lemon meringue pie so I just mix a
mix of a shake oh and then mentally
assign dessert status do it it's my
dessert now good although the other day
I ate discipline yeah you are with me
yes sir
and I was saying it's kind of like doing
a shot of whiskey cuz you know kind of
you do a shot of whiskey go oh yeah you
make it like a paste or just powder
right we've got power did it I ate the
powder that's like the creatine days
yeah so yes Lilly the kool-aid straight
I can be when you make the kool-aid in
the liquor made what oh man I think I
was about to ask you about that isn't I
figured out mid-sentence all right knows
less if or when you do go to buy these
things you go to origin mean calm that's
where they are super krill joint
Wuerffel warfare discipline get the
subscription what I'm saying straight up
do that sounds like a good go now that I
know that the subscription is available
that's like it's obvious that that's the
way to go cuz running out isn't good no
by the way like when you read out yeah I
know that's what I'm kind of mentally
drawing upon to can tell you guys is
very important also at or dominga calm
G's and rash guards if you are about
that guy grab
commitment and you're gonna put on Aggie
in the event of you wanting to put on a
gear or needing to put on a key you get
origin key all made in America also
compression gear which is rash guards
spats mm-hmm approved terminology proved
which are what what's another word for
spats let's say I'm just tuning in
compression pants freshen pants yeah
again this is spats got approved cuz you
found out the root meaning yeah I'm
nonetheless you get them from origin
mean common all mean in America really
cool stuff other stuff on their hoodies
and whatnot anyway just go there you
like something get something good way to
support also if you are into and I
always say cat mainly the kettlebells
you can't on it and you know they have
cattle you know on it right near the
cool kettlebells the primal bells
and by the way I got there I got this
that's right and that's a big big foot
one then Jaco thinks he's all actually
Jocko salty that had a bigger kettle
building him of course he had to go buy
more but nonetheless I got the whole
settled nose bigger than your kennel
yeah but I got the whole set varied
Caribbean or two of them together and
start slinging them yeah I'm sure that's
what he was doing for a while and he's
like there's good a better way to
compete with that code anyway there's
other stuff on there as well actually I
do mention this as well
Mace's and there's like these little
like they're called something bells
they're like these little flat kind of
leather weight steel bells is what
they're called
yeah something there you want to vary up
your workout you know deviate from the
mundane boring workout that you might be
doing right now go there get some cool
stuff good way to support also when you
buy the books that Jocko reviews and
also Mike's book Mike's got three books
yeah books should I say team dog right
yep how to train your dog the Navy SEAL
way also the the K and then you think
there's two others that were essentially
the same book yes one others the same
book SEAL team dog same field team dogs
this young
don't yeah well so there's a there's
Trident cannon warriors and there's Navy
SEAL dogs Navy SEAL dogs is Trident k9
warriors but it's the doctor
ya know version two yep so when you're
gonna get that booked don't worry I got
you go to jackal podcast comm in the
book section it'll be by episode will be
all these books and all the other books
from other episodes all organized take
you to Amazon boom you click buy them
I'm some prime you get the book that
same day sometimes sometimes good way to
support if you're gonna continue to do
it do your other shopping you know that
lawnmower that you're just you know on
the fence about to buy get that to also
subscribe to the podcast if you haven't
already iTunes Google Play stitcher
inning anywhere else you listen to
podcasts just subscribe that's a good
way to support leave a review if you're
in the mood I wouldn't say leave a
review if you're not in the mood no
don't I've heard people say that like
leave a review
oh no matter what no well actually you
know what I'm that's not sure you have
the capacity in your life and a good
sense of humor to leave a funny review
that's cool do it yeah that's don't
Richmond yeah don't if you don't have
the capacity in your life no no it's
gonna take seven minutes right yeah
there's gonna be misspellings in there
right you really want to post that no
just walk away agree the review also
subscribe to youtube because we have a
youtube channel by the way do you have
youtube channel i do actually it it's
yeah you can get there off of micro
uncom also but yeah yeah yeah so
subscribe to mike's as well you think
you don't remember right now I can tell
you about 90% on the micro on website I
didn't put on there so I couldn't watch
the bunch of your videos on that I'm
sure if you just put Mike Ritland yeah
yeah yeah in YouTube not to be confused
with the other one subscribe we got the
vision video version of this podcast and
excerpts and deluxe excerpts so we're
calling them right now okay
and we're gonna work on their another
jockey give me good pep talk the other
day mmm
inadvertent by the way because you
weren't unless he was it seemed
inadvertent that's the thing with this
guy subtle like where he'll give you a
pep top talk and you don't know that
it's a pep talk at the time it's not
that sounds more calculated than ever
yeah at the end I'm like leaving the
hole we drove back from LA whatever and
I'm leaving it you have no idea what I'm
about to do all this stuff I got it all
planned out or whatever and it's like
yeah I don't think jock will realize
like that that really helped you know
what we talked about yeah he does know
numel and share what you talking about
stuff I would say this wait and see yeah
you know what I mean it has something to
do with me being reluctant to post
certain videos sometimes like gun-shy
kinda yeah let let the hands go kind of
let the hands go yeah yeah well the
Wayne Wayne Gretzky quote if you miss
100% of shots you don't take
there you go yeah no part of the
conversation yeah
what that has to do is with is video
sorghum we're gonna release a little bit
more videos different types of videos
but if you like videos in relationship
to this podcast in any capacity just
subscribe to the youtube channel also
chuckle is the store if you don't know
already
it's called chuckles door chuckles Darko
this is where you can get chocolate
podcast shirts discipline equals freedom
shirts victory Emmett make sure it's on
that chuckle where is every single day
and you know some rash guards on there
some hoodies on there you know any kind
of gear choco choco gear really is what
it is a very good way to support also
psychological warfare you know what that
is if you're on the path we call it the
path a campaign against weakness is what
we've always also called it and you hit
those moments of weakness like you know
you can you want to hit the snooze so to
speak literally and figuratively you
want to hit the snooze right
what is heating the snooze in life just
like I can't do it right now I'll do it
later news and rife yeah like me snooze
button should say hit this button and
destroy all of your hopes and dreams the
idea it should say that but hitting that
what is that's like what like III don't
feel like doing it right now I'll do it
in 10 minutes right can I give you a
product recommendation a new jaco
product yeah what do you got developed
on this it's a it's a snooze button
shot-caller yeah
or you can just you know what else you
can do is you can hit the snooze button
you can sleep in and then you can wake
up 20 minutes half an hour later with
that part of your life gone forever with
your with your schedule now being off
with the opportunity improve yourself
physically and mentally gone gone can
never get it back you can take that
feeling you can embrace it then you can
just go ahead and next time you see that
snooze button you can get pissed off and
get up and get out of bed and get after
it
yeah deal and you know what in a more
maybe echo way of thinking about it to
the you don't even benefit from the five
minutes no other way it's sort a No
yeah I'm more tired yeah cuz it's not
like you're like dang I need the nine
minutes of sleep or whatever you know
and then you're like you get up you're
like dang that nine minutes really
helped me it's not like that didn't work
that said you're worse yeah exactly yeah
so don't hit the snooze but in the event
of you needing help not hitting the
snooze you listen a psychological
warfare and this goes for any other
little mom in a weakness like you're
gonna skip the workout for the middle we
know those yeah yeah we do nonetheless I
just got I just got my first like mad
look for Matt go I think bomber no no
you got some before really well not not
on the jujitsu man cuz you've looked at
me real mad on the disease matter
genuine anger by the way nonetheless you
listen to psychological warfare it's an
album with tracks chocolate racks
chocolate telling you why you shouldn't
hit the snooze skip the workout eat
donuts
sugar-coated lies yeah why you shouldn't
procrastinate which is a big deal deal
actually procrastination I think is
worse than heating this mess for what's
the same thing it is the same thing
that's that is yeah it's a it's a
physical and psychological manifestation
of procrastination
without question yeah your snooze but
you're also say procrastinate now yeah
go touch this button and actually in a
way it's even worse actually
straight-up it's even worse because the
snooze button at least has like ten
minutes later the alarms coming back on
see I'm saying procrastination is an
indefinite snooze button maybe we should
call it the procrastination button yeah
that's what it's go that's what it'll be
called on the Jacko alarm clock yeah
yeah boom there it is but that's what
it's like glad to work or for a day Hey
look when Jacko tells you in his terms
why you should or shouldn't do things it
makes sense when you just said the Jack
alarm clock the one of the reasons why
we actually made this was because people
said kept saying oh you should make your
alarm clock you should make an alarm
clock well with this with a
psychological warfare album you can take
those tracks from the album and you can
put them as your alarm clock if you
choose to do that the big warning is if
you're married you don't really want to
do this too loudly because your life
will freak out a couple other things you
can get jock a white tee you can get it
on Amazon and if you if you're looking
to be able to deadlift eight thousand
pounds as a minimum we have people going
above that now if you get jock on white
tee it's a guarantee that you'll be able
to deadlift eight thousand pounds that's
in there right it's on the package yes
yes I mean it's already been approved by
the FDA and the double blind for people
yeah that's soccer white tee you know
what straight up tastes awesome makes
you feel good books again Mike's book
Trident k9 warriors Navy SEAL Dogs team
dog those are all available and also
some books I got some books but for
instance what if you wanted your kid to
work out study eat good food trained
jiu-jitsu and be highly disciplined what
would you would you want that for your
kid the answer is in error invariably
yes you would so I wrote a book called
way the
or your kid so your kid will start
getting in the game overcoming fears
overcoming the layers coming fears not
being picked on making a plan following
through also I just had well soon to
come out another book it's called the
way the warrior kid - it's called Mark's
mission now we go a little bit further
what if you wanted your kid to take
control of their emotions mm-hmm wanted
them to learn and understand the value
of money and how to earn money and how
to save money wanted your kid to learn
about helping other people wanted your
kid to become a leader what if you
wanted those things for your kids well
guess what way the warrior kid to Mark's
mission it's available right now for
pre-order on Amazon so check that out
speaking of warrior kids also there's a
12 year old warrior kid named Aiden and
he has a business he's a businessman at
age 12 he's making soap from goat milk
on his farm he wanted to make good soap
he said can I make jock low soap and I
said do it
Irish Oaks ranch com get some soap from
Aiden the warrior kid and I think I
inadvertently made up the slogan for his
soap it's a simple it's a simple it's
here but there's layers it's an easy
stay clean I've said that's a you know I
always said that that's an old Motorhead
song or it's part of it so it's the
lyrics of a motor hit song and and what
I used to tell whenever somebody tells
me all you know I've been Dre I was
drinking and I haven't drank for six
months or I haven't you know I was doing
coke and I have the new coke for a first
eight months I appreciate it or I was a
drug addict or whatever and this is all
like all mine these people saying the
stuff online and and I always say man
keep it up stay clean now I wasn't
thinking about the literally staying
clean but now we have a proper soap you
know that will help you stay clean
I didn't mean to 12 year old kid with a
business that's pretty impressive yeah
it's pretty that's legit was like the
furthest thing from my mind
yeah you think about what you were doing
in 12 I would I would with my friend
Jeff I would when people were going to
put their trays away in lunch we would
collect their leftover potato chips yeah
and then eat them all we have a pile of
potato chips on our tray yeah and we
just different was I thinking about
running a business was I thinking about
trying to build a business no I was
eating massive amounts of potato chips
which is just other things where I was
at yeah oh they didn't even pay for I
thought it was so awesome free potato
chips yeah cuz never when you're a kid
your parents weren't getting you potato
chips all the time no they have it they
have a mound of potatoes with more
almost more than you could eat but we
did our best to eat them oh yeah
so that's it that's a warrior kid books
also discipline equals freedom Field
Manual get it for people that you
actually care about and want to have
better lives that's people that you want
to win in their lives
the discipline course freedom manual
will give them a very good indication
and the reason I know that is well let's
not even take my experiences from my
life but what the feedback I'm getting
right now people are getting after it
they're losing weight or gaining weight
or or getting more disciplined in their
school in their life and the business
they're getting better so you can get
that and it will show you how why cuz
it's a Field Manual
I mean you don't know what that is that
go I do my favorite kind of manual ok a
field manual actually gives you
instructions in the military you weren't
in the military you know nothing about a
field manual hey if you want the audio
version of that it is not on audible
it's not on audible you can't get it
there it's on iTunes it's on Amazon
music it's on Google Play other mp3
platforms it's an album with track so
that you can use that thing for your
alarm clock too you can put it in your
mixtape what in your mitt what's it
what's it called what in your playlist
now
you just have it in there yeah so if you
pick the ones that you like that hit you
the right way also extreme ownership
combat leadership principles that you
can apply to your business and your life
other people are doing it that's why
that book is still on the Wall Street
Journal bestsellers list it's over two
years old it's still there rocking and
also with that book if you don't just
get it to yourself for yourself get it
for your team up and down the chain of
command it's gonna make your life easier
if you put it up and down the chain of
commit if everyone in your team is
taking ownership we have a good team if
you need some help with leadership at
your company I have a leadership and
management consulting company it's
called a salon front we solve problems
through leadership and we do it all the
time and we do it all over the world me
Wave babban JP Danelle Dave Burke email
info at Ashkelon front comm or you can
go to our website Ashlin front comm of
course we have the muster I throw this
out there
the ultimate leadership conference
that's what I'm calling it the ultimate
leadership conference and really
conference might not even be the right
word it's just it's embedded knowledge
sure that's gonna come at you it's an
experienced gathering it's a gathering
there's no green room I haven't said
that lately there's no green room at the
muster that is a good point there's no
bad I know that's why I've reminded
myself what because I was thinking about
okay well why would people want to come
to this well one reason is there's no
green room there's no backstage we're
out there we're with you you come to the
monster we're hanging out we're having
lunch we're having dinner we're asking
answering questions we're with you there
the whole time we've done for so far
they've all sold out we're only doing
two this year a lot of people are
objecting to this we don't have time to
do more we're only doing two Washington
DC May 17th and 18th in San Francisco
October 17 to 18th
that's it we are not a rock and roll
band on tour as much as I want to be
because people are saying well why don't
you come to Seattle and why don't you
come to Milwaukee and why don't you come
to Norfolk
and why don't you come to Memphis like
we're on a rock tour yeah like we're
just making dates no this is the the
only two we are doing Washington DC May
17th
17th and 18th in San Francisco those are
the dates we can fit the muster in to
our schedule and like I said they're
going to sell out so if you want to come
register to extreme ownership dot-com
we'll see you there and until the muster
if you want to continue this
conversation with any of us you can find
us conversing on the interwebs on
Twitter on Instagram and on
Nach face ebo ha Mike Ritland is at M
Ritland and also as he said Mike Ritland
calm of course echo is at echo Charles
and I am at Jocko willing echo anything
else no thank you
actually I'm where your were at with the
dog thing where it's like hey we can't
get it done through me we got to be
ready to get a dog you know my
daughter's look to get her dog she
didn't know she's fine it's a big deal
but I don't know man you know talking to
you is kind of like I don't know he's
good very influential I mean I can tell
you you can I mean it's like with
anything in your life like you if you
want to do it you'll do it
yeah you got to decide I'm gonna do it
I'm gonna do it right
and you'll do it yeah you know but the
only thing I would caution against is
that realize that that that's carving
out a portion of your day a portion of
your life that something else isn't
gonna be able to fill that yes that's a
you know prioritization component but
yeah but yeah it's so cool to me from
thank you no thank you thanks for having
me appreciate it you know Mike you got
anything else that's it just you guys
keep keep up the good fight I am honored
to be on here and appreciative of of
your guys as times been been great well
Mike again thanks for coming off thanks
for everything you've done
while you were in since you've been out
and everything that you're continuing to
do today I know the dogs have saved a
lot of lives you know
and appreciate that of course thanks to
all the service men and women out there
and I'll go ahead and yes throw out a
special thanks to all the dogs out there
and their handlers everyone in the
military standing face-to-face with evil
thank you for standing the watch for
police law enforcement again and their
dogs firefighters paramedics all the
other first responders thanks for
protecting us while we sleep at night
and to everyone thank you for listening
and sharing and supporting this podcast
but most of all thanks for getting up
early everyday by seven- and attacking
the world with the ferocity of an angry
working dog that is out for blood and
vengeance go and get after it and until
next time this is Mike Ritland and Ecko
and Jocko out